uh super special edition of firing the
kid brian the kid callum decided to go
play grab ass in montreal let me grab as
he's doing a show for the uh just for
laughs that's a good place to be it's a
good place i want to get your thoughts
on that good place to be but he told me
this on monday he goes i won't be here
wednesday
okay okay i gotta find a co-host i gotta
find a co-host i sent out the bat signal
my boy joe coy answered the bell i had
to dude and you're the busiest guy i
know i felt bad asking you really
there's there's two people that i feel
bad ever asking things for it's you and
rogan really so busy you have so much
going on and you don't need anything
from anyone so whenever i text him he's
like oh god here we go here we go man
when you press send oh god that's the
worst when you're contemplating that
that text that you just wrote and then
that's that little blue arrow and you're
like
or or when you're waiting for a response
oh no and you don't hear back how about
when you see
that means that usually the ball cap
means they wrote something and it was
like nah
don't be that mean yeah yeah back to
facebook
i'm gonna sit down you know what i do
when i see the quote bubble disappear i
go no no what what do you want to say
reset come back
you're talking so you're talking
he says go ahead and say it man
that's the thing don't delete that what
what were you gonna say what are you
just sending oh my god i want everyone
to do that every time you see that
little bubble disappear no no no no no
no no no no no no no i'm i'm here
i'm here man i promise i can
i can take it i can what is what is it
yes or no you get it
please well it's the same thing like
don't do this man
don't do this man don't do that it's
your mom don't do this man
it's your mom
please just let me have it where'd you
go
do you need help
talk to me talk to come on
hey you forgot to hit the blue arrow
sometimes i'll just do dot dot question
dot dot dot it's like uh sometimes
again every now and then i'll read
comments if if i open my twitter
instagram up and i see something if it's
negative usually i don't read them but
sometimes i'll get some and then or if
something positive i'll respond but i
don't go through comments yeah and i saw
something super negative on twitter and
i wanted to get and i went you know what
i got this whole long thing and i was
like i'm not gonna yeah
oh that's a good one
yeah you should have dressed just drafts
i write some good [__] too man i've
written some some like when i reread it
i'm like this is [__] gold liar this
one there's no way you can compete all
right you can't combat this come come
back
there's you will not win
i'm so good at this in the draft
no let me delete that
i sent it to my boys derek and hassan i
was like i'm thinking about lighting
this dude up yeah and they're like don't
do it it's not worth it yeah and then
then i'm waiting for a dick to respond
back he goes but every now and then it's
good to let him know
oh you're right you're right you're
right i'm gonna leave it alone man right
bums me out sometimes why do we let that
bother us why do we
why do we let one negative
defeat ten thousand positive outweigh
all the positive it doesn't make any
sense we're wired that way our humans
are wired that way yeah
when you think about it like i mean i'm
sure you have some great positive
memories but usually your brain stores
the negative better so you don't make
the same mistake yeah
oh i get that yeah so that's why it
latches on to the negative yeah
it's the same thing like in the crowd
yeah you see the one person that one
person is not laughing like what
who the [__] where do i come out why why
are you here you know what i hate is
when you you focus on one person that's
not
smiling or laughing hard or even
applauding
and you just focus on the whole show and
then they come to your meet and greet
and go that was [__] phenomenal and
i'm like where was your face are you an
alien what happened to your hands yeah
are you armless [__] what
happened are you a serial killer dude
who was he was your soul here cause just
your body made it no there's people [__]
are you there's people you can watch in
the crowd where it's going great and
they're like this yeah like this
i saw one guy doing like chin they're
raised like chin yeah they're just like
yeah
and then yeah they come mean greet have
you seen this i hate this guy i'm
starting to be no good
this is the whole show right and then
when there's a huge applause break they
do this
oh god
i wonder what that is and then when they
stop applying they go like this
like
during the applause break you decided to
drink [__] you man i wouldn't and now
you want a picture go [__] yourself so
weird to me or i had
had a heckler in uh i think cincinnati
indiana and they actually
had to say something to him like he
wants to kick him out like no let him
what he's fine
and then
he comes he's heckling then comes the
meet-and-greet he's like dude i get all
your shirts man i don't miss a show i
just went then what are you doing what
are you doing dude what do you mean i go
you wouldn't shut the [__] up man like
you ruin it for other people i went you
just can't i went do me a favor don't do
that to any other comic yeah because i
was just having fun i'm like i get it
man i'm telling you you're ruining it
for everybody else yeah that's your your
fun is uh everyone else is no fun god
dude what is that i don't know
what kind of person is that that doesn't
know
the social cues the etiquette the
etiquette how do you not know the rules
they're not waiting for you i was
terrified but before i start doing
comedy when i go to shows like i went to
the laugh factory i was terrified they
were gonna single me out i didn't want
to make a peep yeah i would laugh like
everyone else but i was afraid that i'd
get singled out yeah these people that
come there to do i was like
well we i'm up here i'm up here all the
time with a mic man yeah what do you
think is gonna happen yeah you're gonna
lose have you ever seen a heckler win
never like out with the guy on stage not
one goddamn time if he does you get a
[__] job in their head
yeah in their head do in their head do
they see themselves killing so hard that
the the audience turns around and looks
at them and like here's the show this is
the guy who's that guy that we paid for
the show is right here at table q
[Music]
hey uh get the kid that's at the table
you're the one who was heckling yeah
he's right yeah holy [__]
dude the next big thing i don't want to
ruin tony rock's bit but uh hey i
haven't seen someone crush like that in
the main room and i don't know since
i've been there i was uh so
um i was only gonna do two spots at a
spot in the belly room and a spot in the
main room and the spot and one spot was
at 8 30 i was on to 11. so i just hang
around and watch the other comics yeah
just hanging out and so i'm in the crowd
and tony rock gets in the main room and
i haven't seen him before no do you know
tony robbins of course i started with
tony i don't yeah dude yeah absolutely
destroyed
and he was just freestyling too and he
he was talking uh he was talking about
the wise guy in the room yeah that's one
guy he goes oh you guys married he's no
on a date and he goes i don't understand
that and he's talking about
basically his whole i don't want to give
away his joke but his joke was how he
thinks it's funny when people bring
dates to stand up yeah and then people
associate the guy that brian to stand up
that he's the funny guy but really they
should be [__] comedians yeah yeah
he's like i'm the one that did all the
work yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah [__]
that guy i was laughing so hard what are
you funneling that you're funneling the
laptop
no yeah he's like you associate him
being funny he goes he's not funny yeah
i'm funny he paid it you go back after
him yeah he's no going over with me this
is my [__] it was so funny oh dude
tony yeah tony when i came up through
the laugh factory it was tony dane
uh
god bob saget monsters yeah and those
are the guys i had to like always i was
always in rotation following those cats
monsters so yeah man
i didn't realize how good uh tony rock
was yeah tony's great i i won't he's
good i was so fired up man i went in the
back and i don't know him at all i went
dude inspiring i think i was too much
energy for you yeah yeah yeah he's like
jesus christ i gave him a hug i was like
it was so good he's like thanks man
it was so good though man yeah you i
don't think you know this but your hugs
aren't normal hugs i had no idea you
know that right because you used to uh
you know choke out people i i do you
don't really know
between put to sleep or just hug
congratulations i apologize because i've
hugged you before and um i think it was
your
uh your chest muscle was inside of my
throat got too much yeah and you're like
got your coffee and i'm like can you
wake me up
dude i like the way i think the waitress
has said to come so i could tell she's
like too much
too much because i was like yeah what's
up she's like oh all right yeah yeah i
went too much brendan is that is that is
that something uh
like like physically like you you really
don't know that you're uh
if i'm excited i don't you don't i don't
like if i'm really excited to see
someone like sometimes with brian he's
like dude that that was intense really
or like i was shooting this movie and
they go hey we really want you to i was
playing this drunk at a bar and like we
really want you to grab the actor like
really like sling him around like really
like dude he can handle me okay and so
i'm pretending i'm all drunk and i
noticed this famous celebrity at the bar
i start grabbing him and i'm like this
and he can tell he's like out and we and
we get done goes uh jesus christ give me
a second yeah no and he looks at the
directors
yeah yeah yeah and the drag comes again
so we like what you're doing we like
what you're doing a little less yeah a
little less i'm like well yeah but
remember you told me he can handle it
you want me to go full board like
we made a mistake let's tone it down
you're going for the belt again
yeah yeah this is trying to see yeah
this isn't there's no cage there's no
cage uh you don't see a fence around you
do you matter of fact we got we we'd
like you to leave we're good yeah thanks
movie a matter of fact i'm texting
hollywood right now yeah yeah yeah
you're right you're done you're out yeah
in fact you're tapping out you're
meathead yeah you're tacked out of
hearts yes
you're tapped out of hollywood you can't
i was i was embarrassed yeah because
they're like to throw them around and i
could tell
like he was trying to still play the
role but it was hurting yeah
but you don't know that you're that
physical huh they told me that like i'm
just trying to do my job but like i
hugged you outside and i was like jesus
christ i know it's a lot i'm like the
same your whole [__] arm i'm like
that's exactly what you are big saint
you're the big saint bernard you can't
get mad at that [__] thing people
like
around his neck dude people love saint
bernards you should put a keg around
your neck that's exactly
yeah
you just [__] hug
you just want to sit on the couch there
that's you yeah right there and that's
you dude i love saint bernards if they
didn't shed so much i'd 100 oh 100 yeah
you have dogs no
i hate them no i'm trying i love them i
love to i have a we have a uh a dog but
it stays at the mommy's house where's my
son it's just a lot of restaurants too
much hair i'm always on the road but
he's such a cute kingston's his name
what kind of dog it's a it's a a shelter
we did uh what they call it poor
person's dog yeah yeah poor person poor
person
yeah i uh
dogs dog's a lot of responsibility right
now i'm trying to uh what kind of dog do
you have
uh uh multilateral a multi dragon no no
no uh
it's kind of a combination of uh of a
german shepherd it's a trained uh canine
dog oh cool yeah we had some security
issues not anymore got this navy seal
dog is this real no yeah it's trade oh
yeah it's a cos only really you only
speak german to it no it's very intense
dad
not a family dog he like he
controls the border
kind of does his own yeah he's a
psychopath my uncle was he listens to
the kill sheriff there you go and and it
was so cool to see him and i still
remember the dog's name jarvis his name
was jarvis and every time uh
if you went there you play with them you
get to play you get to hug them but the
minute my uncle put his uniform one time
that [__] was and he and my
uncle would be like don't pet him don't
walk up to him that's how this does he's
working yeah this he he's literally like
a navy seal and he's just really intense
your dog has face makeup on he has war
paint on water at all times i'm like it
doesn't make sense dude saturday but he
uh
he uh no one robs the house on saturday
nah that's what he's doing yeah that's
when they get you yeah but here's the
thing though is people go oh you never
post about your dog how come you don't
post about your dog yeah it's like
because i don't want intruders no i have
a dog's become you're getting lit up
yeah i don't know he's that good uh
trained professional yeah what yeah so
when they train him like that a malinois
that's and he is so intense that's what
he is yeah oh that's a dope dog right
there that one looks like he can run and
eat yeah i think he was in uh i think
right it looks like he could run and eat
look at him yeah i think he's part of
stealing six or some [__] he is
just all business yeah look at him
he looks like he has face makeup on like
a navy seal yeah i don't trust him like
at night his eyes just open up and he's
in the bush
right you know what i'm talking about he
has night vision at all yeah he's just
[__] he's always got night vision he
always thinks just anarchy is happening
yeah look at him look at that
yeah he looks cute there don't let him
fool you man so is that the same color
as your dog my dog with a black face uh
my dog yeah uh
a little darker
oh he's cute as [__] mine's more like
that oh that's dull name's nani we'll
rip your dick off really straight up oh
people go with his paws he doesn't even
use his hands no yep with his ears um
yeah people are he's like you never post
about your dog i'm like yeah i don't i
don't want people to know that's him
right there that's him he's actually a
human that's actually he's actually a
human being on the right and that's yeah
that's him is that just the name
right there
yeah it's a navy seal i actually hired
the guy that shot uh
oh there he is right there with the hat
that's him there yeah this is christ
few biscuits every now and then but yeah
yeah yeah
that's what he's saying right there
can i go outside and pee
i'll hold it but i'm just saying can i
go outside and pee
he still repeats the same thing as if
he's barking just none yeah
um
yeah dog's super intense yeah i do want
a saint bernard i do want to say banana
do you really it's just a lot but i
don't want the responsibility like my
son's three and a half now
and we're potty training him yeah i'm
sure you had to go through this with
your kiddos yeah and it's such a beast
man and it's
so frustrating yesterday man
it really tested my patience really the
way you do it unless so
um
you know he's three and a half and he
goes to school and he's like on the
later end of being potty trained up and
on diapers so i told my grandma like we
we gotta we have to do this we can't
wait long we have it's on us does he
have uh pull-ups does he usually well he
he does but then
we're like we need to get him regular
underwear yeah like he's on the one the
only guys in his class and he's a lebron
james with three-year-olds so yeah he
can't be this giant athletic kid [__] in
his pants while everyone else is
controlled so the way you do it for
parents i don't know if he's the only
kid that that when he walks it crinkles
did you hear his underwear yeah it's
it's not a good man it's not good all
the other kids are why is it in your
pocket
poopies in my pocket it's not good man
so i'm too tall to have poopies in your
pocket he looks like he's 16 just
[__] his pants big is he that big
yeah he's he's 99 percentile for
three-year-olds wow so i tell my grandma
we got to figure this out so we've been
doing it for a while now and then we had
a breakthrough and he's just been going
backwards
and
it's
so we talked to his pediatrician she's
like he's very stubborn so you just
gotta you gotta bear down and [__] do
it and i'm like oh there's no
three-year-old's gonna break me i'm
gonna outlast this dude i fight in the
ufc for god's sakes yeah dude he's not
broke he almost broke me really i think
he's a navy seal too yeah i think he's
training with my dog in the backyard
dude
it's um because you you wait then you're
like we're not leaving til you go poop
leaving he's like cool man yeah three
hours i'm in there laying on the ground
and my girl's like what the [__] are we
gonna do i went i'm not he's gonna break
before i break
sure enough papa broke about four hours
in all right all right well i got to go
do stand up i'm like all right [__] it
all right dude you win
i got a bid out of it though yeah it's a
good bid you got a bit i love that [__]
i got a bid out of it my favorite bit
out of it man that was the one good
because my girl was sitting there my son
just there like all right dudes good
luck and so i'm making i'm trying to
make my girl laugh it's which we're not
doing well so i'm trying and she's dying
i went ah [__] i bet i could do
something on stage so i went i and i was
driving the comedy store i'm like i'm
just going to open up with this see
where it goes it's coming it's not like
my regular crowd i'm just gonna see how
it goes
and so i do in the belly room it's new
material night so it works there but
that's new material at night and i told
myself i went um
all right i'm not gonna do the stuff
that i know that works i'm open with
this i have two new bits i gotta do it
no matter who's
in front of me i gotta do it yeah so uh
i'm in between shows i'm waiting and
they run up to me go hey callan's not
coming theo's late we need you to close
the the main room like what like when
you close the main rail who's on right
now they go sebastian like
very cool yeah no problem yeah yeah sam
because i'm like oh [__] and so i get up
there and i'm in the back and like do i
just do the stuff that i know it works
and then i'm in this argument myself i
don't know if you're you're so you know
you've been doing it so long but i'm in
the back i'm like god
do i just do the stuff that works
and then i'm i'm in this argument in the
back right where i'm going i'm like you
[__] said you're gonna do the new
stuff man yeah you said you're gonna do
the new stuff and so i went out there
did the new stuff good it worked pretty
well that's what you do yeah i always i
always make sure to do new stuff like
uh yeah but it's tough you know what i'm
saying because sebastian i've been one
of the best comics yeah all time i mean
crushing like just destroying feels on
before
but that's what you do it's the store
yeah that's what you that's that's where
you work out man that's where you know
that's what stand-up's all about i love
it man i love following strong [__]
comics you know what i mean that's my
all my ultimate goal
is especially when i was coming up
during that time well yeah without you
the guy that people are afraid to follow
you know this
yes yes mission accomplished no i i just
enjoy it but i love i still love like
like i haven't you know i'm on on
vacation right now so i've been going up
to like open mics and just you know
trying to step out and i love
like seeing who's going up and crushing
and then like
hey can i go up and follow you know what
i mean but i'm only gonna do
stuff that i'm thinking of right now
yeah yeah i don't want to do what i did
on the spot no that i'm just gonna go up
and talk and wing it before before you
came in you're talking about how you
shot your special would you say 15 years
ago yeah
oh you're talking about my first one
yeah yeah dude that was crazy i was
looking back at it you were about you're
gonna start telling me like save it from
the podcast yeah i gotta i want people
to hear this yeah it's just uh i know
where it's gonna go but yeah no uh just
i remember when i got it
it was i'm talking about my half hour
though yeah forgot the half hour
was it your first special half hour my
yeah that was my first like that was my
first big thing was my comedy central
half hour and how long were you doing
kind of before you got that half hour i
was about
15 years in
yeah
15 yeah 15 years in
and i and i got it and then uh how'd you
get it auditioning no um
i don't know how i got that oh i do know
how i got it i got off stage and uh doug
herzog saw me where where were you at uh
at the gibson theater
and i opened and i it was open for it i
think it was the mancia tour oh nice and
then uh i got off stage and he walked
right up to me and he goes
have we talked to you about a special
and i go no he goes i'm gonna give you a
special and that that was doug herzog he
was the president
yeah and that was it i i literally got
it from him especially at the time like
comey central was that albeit yeah that
was 15 years ago yeah it was like 18
years ago big boy yeah it was literally
i think my son was one i think
i can't remember like so don't quote me
i don't want you guys to go research in
and who cares figure it out it was about
is like right when my son was like like
maybe two years old so whatever like 14
years ago and so did you get on the
who's the first person you told uh my
mom called my mom aunt huh called her
called her and she didn't give two [__]
she was just like yeah they don't get it
no she don't know what kelly central was
she didn't know what that was you know i
mean and then she was still like are you
still going to be at wells fargo like
what the [__] oh no i'm shooting at a
half hour special like
is it weird nothing is well fargo going
to be okay with you calling in like what
are you well fargo going to give you 30
minutes off yeah are they going to give
you 30 are you going to do it in between
your break
like on lunch break then go shoot and
then come back is there anything more
frustrating but like nothing drives me
more nuts when i want someone to share
the same experience with me and they
don't understand no my dad like when i
wou when showtime started coming there
goes yeah that's cool so in this speech
and i have a bit about now my dad goes
so in your speech uh how exactly are you
gonna go speech yeah speech what the
[__] are you talking about what are you
talking about speech i want you uh you
ruined it yeah you're really everything
god dang it yeah i remember when i got
the tonight show i was at uh montreal in
a comedy festival yeah i did the
montreal just for laughs and then i did
uh new faces and right when i walked off
stage uh ross and bob they were the
bookers for the tonight show and uh and
ross uh
[Music]
uh mark and ross walked up to and they
were like save that for the for the
tonight show we want that whatever you
did right right there do that say that
we want that on the tonight show and i i
my heart because i was working at
nordstrom rack at the time and i was
just like you know shelving shoes and i
was just like oh
i [__] made it oh and i went and
called my mom
and it was the [__] worst response
god the [__] worst response like just
nothing like mom i got the tonight show
oh it's so tonight it'll be on tonight
no no i got i booked it okay but when
like well like they'll give me a date
and time oh okay well um you know your
auntie is having a birthday this
saturday and are you going to be able to
go like what the [__] wait no we're not
sharing the same excitement dude i'm
still on the tonight i just got on stage
i just got booked okay but can you bring
maybe a cake
or something
and i just remember by mom it's
heartbreaking
my family grew up we idolized porsches
that was the [__] yeah no one in my
family had one i bought one this is
years ago i bought one as soon as i get
in the car bluetooth first when i call
my dad my dad goes uh what's going on
here you're talking to your son in a 911
career my dad goes
what year i go brand new papa brand new
just like we we talked about he goes
yeah my friend has the uh turbo
just get on you real quick yeah well
this isn't the turbo yes yeah those are
nice man the turbos i went well yeah no
again you keep bringing up the turbo i
don't have the turbo this is just your
911 he goes those are cool yeah but my
friend just talks about friends turbo i
went you know i'm gonna go i'm gonna go
now yeah you've ruined the moment yeah
you ruined everything there how about
how about when i called my dad my girl
when i found out my girl was pregnant so
so my girl's super mexican right yeah so
she calls her mom super mexican by the
way is a mexican that can save lives
correct superheroes super mexican yeah
not worried about walls no walls they
laugh at their walls
ice bring it yeah that's a super mix
that's a super so um
she calls when she finds out she's
pregnant i'm out shooting something for
ufc tonight and she keeps blowing me up
i come home and go what and she goes she
has this little thing says uh you know
uh pregnant and she has a sign she's
crying she calls her mom you know
mexican she's so happy she puts her mom
a speaker she's like mama we're pregnant
and her mom's freaking out she's like
this is the best meal
i'm like yeah okay cool i go let me call
my let me call my dad yeah watch this
get ready for this you ready for this
and i call my dad and i go hey papa and
he goes what's up he's so serious and i
go uh
joanna's pregnant he goes
this is on speakerphone by the way your
phone and i'm like this small
i'm looking at my grandma and he goes
okay have a good day and my girl's like
what the [__] are you
no he's joking he's [__] he's joking
he's joking he ruined that moment too
though that's
[__] funny
did he really oh yeah goes do you talk
about this on stage not that way that's
a [__] great one i want your son he
does have to actually hear what grandpa
said the day he was conceived
right her family is fine you got to put
that
yeah there's a goddamn pinata already
filled with diapers like oh what is it a
boy or a girl we just found out oh i
can't wait to find out you're dead hey
kill it
yeah [__] destroy it man yeah
you still got that uh you still got that
navy seal dog feed it to that yeah give
it to that thing man yeah yeah put your
girlfriend's vagina next to that dog
kids are the worst kids are the worst
you know you were my kid i [__] hated
you how about this with this my mom
my mom's getting cheeseless in the
podcast sorry mom you know it's true
though my mom
my mom comes out and seen my son and my
son's like having one of his issues this
is like two years ago so he's like one
and a half he's just having one of those
fits or something like that and my mom's
not used to it you know yeah and i go
hate you stay in a hotel and i go uh hey
mom so you want to get lunch about this
after my son forgot she goes uh i could
tell she goes no i don't i don't i don't
i actually don't um she dropped me off
at the hotel i went we just we just
picked you up she goes i know it's just
this whole kid thing i just wasn't made
to have kids
i went what she said
i went
oh yeah my feelings are so hurt i went
oh that's cool yeah i'll drop back off
the hotel and just was like
so and then she got out looked on my
girl girl just wasn't made to have a kid
so that's cool you know what that
doesn't are you being serious right now
yeah that's it your mom said that yeah
with the straightest face with the
straightest face just like she's not
looking at that i hope she's laughing at
this my mind has a great sense of humor
not that day not that day
but okay that doesn't make any sense my
body wasn't made to have kids no [__] i
wasn't meant to have kids oh you no she
wasn't [__] that doesn't make sense
why would she say such an awful lot
she's not a kid friendship she's hating
two kids in the car just like you are
you're a kid she's not a kid person
are your listeners hearing this
your mom basically said i wasn't
supposed to have you and i sure are so
[__] don't want you you're [__]
sure it's not going to be around this
kid this kid [__] no but that's what i
had to you drop me off
why do you listen to your dad that's
when she sends you the car why don't you
listen to your dad
you didn't need to have this
your son's just sucking up
he has no idea he's six foot tall in his
in his car seats lebron james jersey
[__] in his pants size 11 shoe
ridiculous
what one and a half years old your dad
your son takes his pacifier off does
grandma not like me what's grandma's
[__] deal dude what the [__] the [__]
is wrong with grandma grandma has her
issues okay grandma's fine she's just
yeah well i just went kaka why [__] my
pants again yeah no one's taught me how
someone stopped that dad
you don't [__] grandma
i'm a [__] grandma we should be grandma
where's my boobie
where's my bb where's my bb
jesus christ what's your son's name
tiger tyle of course
ugh [__] great well i don't know what
it is i don't know what it is i don't i
don't know why yeah i i don't call
people i only call certain people during
big moments like even my brother he's
not he's just a very
calm like nothing he's he's never low
he's never high it's always that flat
line frequency yeah i get like yo i just
i won the lottery man 300 million
dollars i would text them and whatever i
text them like okay just won the lottery
300 million dollars
response no matter what it is cool cool
cool cool
or k
sounds good okay sounds good all right
all right all right
yeah so you gotta you gotta call certain
people
you gotta you gotta decide who you're
gonna call to share your money yeah man
but i hope there's more moments i think
my mom's [__] on every moment
what's wrong with them i don't know are
they haters i don't know what it is it's
never enough i just don't yeah i know
it's never it's never anything you do is
not cool yeah what would be cool oh this
is my favorite i know would be cool if
you become a senator
oh god
[Applause]
yeah if you become a senator joseph
perfect how about my mom text me because
i need to talk to you i get a great idea
i'm like i wonder what it is i call her
this before uh they casted someone
else's batman she goes you should be the
new batman
i'm sorry what are you saying you should
be the next batman you make a great bat
mango
yeah no doubt no that's what you want to
tie with you thank you for that yes
thank you they booked ben affleck for
that and uh i'm not an actor yeah so
that's kind of that's the problem there
yeah mom and you they just don't give
batman to guys that they think look like
batman so you thought great idea yeah
mom do you think i should just walk them
and say i'm batman and then they'll give
it to me batman i'm batman
you know heart is getting batman
there's not an application mom no mom
and also those guys the [__] the guys
that become batman have been doing it
forever yeah ah
my mom i remember when i first started
um my mom
my mom was emailing because she she
wasn't now she's savvy now my mom's on
facebook and stuff but i'm talking like
you know back in the day my mom would go
you know i
email you all the time and you don't
respond
i'm like who do you
who are you emailing mom
jokoy.com i'm like okay that's
that's not an email mom
come on mom
and and the whole time angry as [__] not
answering my texts just not answering my
phone call because she's mad that i'm
not responding
to something that's not being sent to me
old school man jockoy.com and i've been
telling everyone to email you at
jokoy.com all right well good mom that's
thanks for telling them to go to my
website old school man parents are old
school dude break your heart yeah break
your goddamn heart so going back to your
special though so that came out that was
15 15 years ago something like that
when it came out was it life changing
for you because no no because now it's a
different
different landscape yeah completely
different lent this guy's laughing
no it wasn't though it was because it
wasn't
you know comedy central was the only
outlet you know what i mean and like and
then they were still dealing with
original content and they weren't really
uh
promoting their their specials you know
what i mean they're kind of and it's
kind of especially that one that was a
half hour special so that was like kind
of like this uh
it was kind of like in a bulk got lost
it got lost
yeah
and i love the stuff that i was talking
about
but i was watching it i wasn't watching
it i was like looking at it because
watching it means i was like like
watching this i was like oh god like
skipping through it real quick just like
ah [__] okay that was documented that
was a part of my life yeah there's
nothing worth it yeah it had my old
teeth in it it had uh
no yeah i pull up it's half hour the
half hour that's that's my hour
because right after that they gave me an
hour
but the half hour i was looking at and i
was just like jesus christ man it was
crazy any of these no i've been comedy
central yeah comedy central half hour
special
but it's just crazy to look back at that
stuff man and
i'm sure you're super proud of it yeah
you know you don't yeah you're not
pulling up [__] who is this guys there
it is right there to your right that's
it
that's it season 12.
that's it
look at that dude unbelievable don't
play it please 21 minutes yeah you see
the teeth in it oh dude the teeth are so
bad look at your face look at that look
at this look what they throw it freeze
it on
it's actually on comedy essentials
oh
okay
but if you go to images
yeah it didn't go there though it still
didn't is there any of these no oh there
it is top right all the way to the far
right yeah that's it
that's it let's see his grill
i mean you've aged great adrian's age
yeah i aged way better when i was
dealing with really bad sleep apnea
that's a prada shirt by the way i paid
like a thousand dollars for that very i
was oh dude i always i was always faking
it
i was always faking it bro i would spend
every [__] penny i had that was that
was productive from new york that's dope
i bought that i bought that in soho i
still i still have that shirt that's
cool it's a stretch prada
it's got the the little things on the
top here i forgot
yeah that's it yeah i got i wish you
could see my feet i had my i had some
threes on oh yeah mm-hmm i had some
jordan threes probably baggy or jeans
i'd assume bag your jeans
and um
but like just yeah i mean there it is
man dude
look at my teeth it's so bad
so bad dude who is that i don't you look
1 000 times yeah man so crazy
i i've had such bad sleep apnea really
so
so bad dude you look i was falling
asleep behind so much more well-rested
now yeah
yeah thanks cpap machine
awesome thanks money it takes money
thanks money mm-hmm you say money don't
buy happiness i beg the difference oh
man he's a little happy now oh so happy
you can buy happiness it's on amazon
dude
look at that look at that tooth right
there
look at that one tooth
i mean that is candy corn in the back of
my mouth you got corn nuts that's corn
nuts right there that's ranch flavored
corn nuts in the back of my mouth and
look at your grill now oh maybe that's
that's teeth i know hands down i kind of
want to i want to do something big big
shout out to dr mcdonald yeah you got to
do something yeah that's bad yeah thank
you yeah that's venom are you venom
in spiderman are you back
um dude look at that well see that
crunchy i'm surprised
none of those fell out while i was
talking
that's how i'm not even joking man i
fell on a rock when i was a kid and
literally yeah two years after this
special
i i i started making money and i
remember i saved up uh dude this is
crazy i i made so much money on that
tour but i just mentor uh when i opened
for mencia i i i made so much more i
didn't spend any of the checks cause
carlos would give you
money from each city yeah each each show
he was giving me money and i didn't
spend anything he was he paying you well
no
you know you know the rumors
and uh i mean it was okay
you know it's opening money but it was a
but i took the money
and uh
and literally i put it all in my son's
college fund smart man yeah like
literally and i it was that was like my
way of telling my mom i told you i can
provide for my son like that's what that
was like i wanted to get yeah my whole
goal was
let me get this college out of the way
and let me pursue
my dream without you you know because i
remember there was times when my mom was
like just quit already
like it's done
you just
get a full-time job now you're done like
you have a son now like she was telling
me that like i'm sure and i get where it
comes from it was coming from a good
place you know i mean she didn't want my
son to struggle don't you think parents
are different now though like i see you
and i will because yeah we're a
different oh one huh i feel like even
parents who don't know anything about
show business or sports anything like
that like well there's actually a lot of
examples of dudes not going to college
or not taking that traditional path and
kind of killing it yeah there's you have
so much more access because of social
media and digital services that where
you see
all these people who didn't take the
conventional road yeah to to yeah
success yeah and those well now there's
so many outlets so many platforms i mean
you're talking about when i started i
was cutting up
cards at kinko's and you know flyers and
putting them in you know going to the
mall parking lots and putting them in
windshields you know what i mean and
renting out theaters and do you think
you could do that now like let's say
there's a young joe coy out there in l.a
right now i would still do it i still
didn't he's like oh i'm cutting up
things putting
you know like i'm still making flyers to
this day
i i just made i just made 10 000 flyers
for my netflix special you just like the
litter because you don't need it yeah
you do
yeah you do you
yeah everyone needs it yeah everyone
if you
cut i mean you know man you're a
businessman like people like tangible
[__]
there's still a group of people that
like to ha they love to physically grab
something from you just to say i i got
this you know we look just uh you
remember when they took the the cd away
and said it's all
streaming now like you don't go
you don't it's not the same anymore the
same like i loved the packaging i loved
opening it
there's people out there that still love
it and there's young kids that that want
to feel that
you know what i mean and i i that's why
i do it
what do you do this is abandoned i've
never even thought of this i make i mean
i just made 20 000 flyers i get them
printed i don't have to go to kinko's
anymore and cut it up you're like but i
get it on the good card stock i make
sure that it's matte so i can sign it
with a silver pen so i do you sign them
at your shows at my shows i put them on
the tables
bro just because your fans know that you
have a netflix special
there's people in your office right now
that have no idea that i have a netflix
special and that's the person i want to
reach
it's still there
you know what i mean not everybody knows
like i like my whole my whole uh thought
process
uh with my with my career is
uh yeah i'm sold out but i'm still gonna
do radio
you're still gonna do press oh are you
kidding me radio is king to this day
it's still king interesting oh to this
day
because it just is like there's still
that you know
i would argue there's a reason this is
king huh
well 100 podcast is king but you gotta
you still got to face the fact that
there's two three million people
listening to la radio right now in the
morning at least at least so why aren't
you talking to him
that's live man like you that's your
chat that's your channel so when you do
why wouldn't you go on there and talk
about your podcast
that's you that's you assuming that
everybody in los angeles knows about
this show that's that's that's a that's
a brave assumption
you want to win
it is it's bad but you're not dumb no
you're not but you've got to understand
there's a reason why big boy is still
[__] bad ass out here there's a
reason why j cruz has a show that's why
the woody show is syndicated that's why
bob and tom had like those markets and
those those those shows and those
platforms exist for a reason so when you
go into a city like i'm in nashville
next week when i go to nashville that's
when you press and i always go
who is it what do they want me to do bro
you should play every i will play soccer
mom channel i will go to
the pop radio i will do anything
i'll go to a talk show i don't give a
[__]
like talk to them do do me they love you
if you did that that's a great
relationship to have interesting
like how cool is it to go into a place
and go i'm sold out i'm just here to say
hi like that's cool yeah and they love
you and they appreciate you for that and
i had three shows at the window sold out
six months in advance i i my shows were
in june they were sold out in january i
still did a full media run in vegas
as if the show only had two tickets sold
to to and then you push everything i did
every news outlet media radio everything
in vegas and i did not have to be there
i'm listening yeah i'll do that from now
on yeah man
you sell
but you got to maintain that and you
know and and like i said not everybody
knows that you just because you're sold
out doesn't mean everybody knows you're
there oh no you ever leave a market and
they get a tweet going hey when you come
to nashville it's like i was just
dude that breaks my heart yeah when
someone goes job when the f when you
come to indianapolis
i was in last weekend and and the reason
why is because you thought the pod let
them know
but if you would have done you're right
here's the other thing so when i was in
indianapolis um i did um this like in a
radio interview in espn but it's a local
like indianapolis espn station i didn't
want to do it i kept blowing it off my
brother was like hey man they really
want you to do this just do it it's like
all right i do it the guy was great
really you know a lot of these uh radio
dj's been to it forever yeah really good
dude i get done and uh i get a text some
club goes whatever you did [__] move
some tickets yeah my brother texted me
goes man so many guys i work with just
heard you on the radio i'm like what the
that [__] still works yes
it's not that i didn't come up
i came up with it in a different kind of
like a podcast as king you don't you
don't need to do this other stuff
podcast is king but so is radio no what
i'm saying is it's
that that's another platform that still
exists yeah you're right and and like
yeah podcast is king but like dude
morning tv is still the [__]
yeah like morning news how's it going
ktla are you kidding me
like you should be on ktla you should be
like you talk to them you're going to
hate me you want to hear this what for
ktla for promotion my special you didn't
do it
i pretended i was sick i'm pretending
you're on tv i'm pretending you're
looking at me right now what the [__]
are you doing i know i know that dude i
know
yes you do that i shouldn't talk to sam
reuben i should have got a call from joe
coy yeah man i that's to me and that's
in anything you do though to just assume
that
everybody knows your business oh i have
i have a i have a i have a billboard up
so everyone should come to my restaurant
no man you need to go out there and tell
everybody you have a restaurant i'm with
you i don't assume everybody i'm not
that naive no i know you know it's not
that big i'm well my thing is i'm like
it's not my demographic they're older
isn't that what you want i should do it
yeah you're right
that's the one that that yeah man you're
you're you're eating your words right
now that's not my demo what the [__]
what is your demo your demo is anything
that anyone that likes to laugh there is
no age yeah you're right there is no
race
like i sold out in singapore how the
[__] did that happen
well no i'm just saying and you can too
yeah for sure yeah for sure yeah 100
yeah
like that like you should always look at
somebody and not hate on them but be
inspired by them like yo that dude sold
out an arena i can sell an arena 100 100
yeah 100 always use that as inspiration
oh let let the haters hate because
that's only going to feed your fire yeah
anyone that hates is just going to be
only for the only person that gets
affected by
shouting out hatred or or or throwing
hate your way they're the only ones that
suffer because they're using all their
energy to promote your product yep
that's how you got to look at [__]
don't ever think of like yo this dude's
hating on me that's going to affect my
business no it's not it's going to help
your business
because you're that guy is giving other
them peop uh a chance to figure out
whether or not they hate you make their
own assumptions that's all he's doing
he's going hey you guys i hate that guy
what are your thoughts
probably about eighty percent of you be
like i kind of like them so thanks for
telling me yeah thanks and then the
other twenty percent is like yo with you
and those [__] you don't want
anyway i asked you i went i went hey how
do you deal with hate and you just sent
me a picture of a racehorse with
blinders
i did
i literally he goes how
because it's real i always ask people
way more successful like how do you deal
with like haters and negativity and you
just i mean he didn't say anything he
just put sent me a picture [__] race
or these horses [__] a racehorse and
the horse is like [__] with blinders
that [__] only has one thing in
front of them the [__] prize in front
of them yep
and all your haters are the are the
people sitting in the stands betting
against you yep
horse number five is gonna suck that
look at him look at the legs on the
horse number five but how that's and the
horse number five doesn't even see them
he doesn't care he doesn't give up he
doesn't care about their opinions he's
gonna show them that i'm gonna win and
that's you you're the [__] racehorse
with the blinders on bro yeah and
remember everyone in the stands wishes
they were a [__] race horse correct
everyone wants to be the wrong hands
down everyone in that audience wishes
they were on stage that's why they're
paying to come see you correct
hands down
you won already it doesn't matter like
it and that's like i always say like i
always say this like it doesn't matter
what you do in life man like there's
haters in every aspect of what you know
everything everything you could be at
your workplace dude imagine oh for sure
but imagine kevin durant yeah best
basketball player on earth maybe the
most skilled hey you know i'm biased i'm
from seattle we drafted that guy
like i'm in love with he's he's my
favorite player yeah anything about
kevin durant the hate got so bad he
created fake burner accounts yeah to
roast people online because yeah he
didn't want to deal with it that's crazy
i love that guy yeah i love him i love
that guy i got a brooklyn jersey coming
got i got to get the brooklyn god man
you know that it's the absolute you know
if anyone should know you're
you're an athlete one thing i hate is a
guy that's
not really an athlete but likes to talk
like like an athlete and like i don't
know what that injury is i just know
that that's usually the time that these
these players start to come down from
their reign it's a bad one it's a bad
one but i mean it took kobe down it took
a lot of players here's my thing with
that kobe was older when it happened
right yeah kevin durant in his prime
like he's literally in his prime and i'm
not going to assume that kevin drantz
can come back worse because kevin durant
yeah so he's so talented he's so
physically gifted i'm gonna assume he
might be the guy that comes back even
better like a.d with his knee surgery
yeah uh adrian peterson everyone goes oh
that need yo other guys were ruined yeah
he came back stronger yeah even though
he was older he came back stronger with
technology and these guys are such
freaks yeah i don't know if he can base
like they go well kobe was never the
same i get that kobe is older his whole
career was behind him he was in his
twilight years kevin dranton is prime
yeah and with technology now i think
he's gonna be good i know it was just it
was crazy because i'd never seen that
injury
physically happen before it's crazy
right i couldn't believe my eyes when i
saw it when they i was like whoa it was
quiet enough because when the achilles
pops it's loud it's loud oh it's like
you've heard them popped i've heard a
pop
[Applause]
that's something you guys
actually do right like you can actually
pop the achilles oh for sure and so
you've seen that happen right god damn i
i mean i don't that was that was the
saddest thing to see that
oh
it was heartbreaking for me especially
because i still have that sonic jersey
that i bought my son when we drafted him
yeah and it was just like you know i was
so mad when they went to okc
like you know i was praying like in my
head i thought we were going to win some
lawsuit and they were going to come back
you know what i mean so i saved the
jersey and then then i was happy you
know and then when he finally won i was
so happy but yeah i'm just a fan of him
it's interesting too like people hate on
kevin durant like oh well he went to
golden state it's not really his team so
it doesn't count uh that was 100 percent
his team yeah i mean you can i mean
right now
you could say it's staff oh it's steph's
but i think kevin durant was the best
player on the court and well what
happened when they didn't have him yeah
like they didn't exactly well they were
also saying that you know there are
other players that were
not someone
yeah
but bro let's just say with him on the
court they were the best team they were
the best team it was night and day when
he was on the court he's so [__] good
it's amazing like he's what is he six
eleven uh he plays like he's six one
seven footer who can dribble unstoppable
great shooting yeah
i mean he's everything ridiculous
ridiculous
and that's that's another guy that just
sits you know getting getting hated on
24 7.
yeah that's great so just imagine well
think about lebron
oh it's way too many people here and
this is my theory on lebron
is
because you grew up with michael jordan
right everyone my brother's the biggest
michael jordan fan so people everyone
should be so you everyone should be
right everyone loves michael jordan well
knife yeah we'll get to that but now it
gets as a basketball player yeah yeah
outside you can be a little difficult i
heard but anyways so on the michael it's
michael jordan we all wear jays who grew
up idolizing michael jordan so the guy
that they said well he's better michael
you're already you're setting him up for
hate yeah so no one gets more hate in
professional sports i don't think than
lebron oh my brother really doesn't hate
on too many people my brother [__]
hates lebron james that's correct i go
oh because you're the biggest michael
jordan fan that's why and that's why i
think he gets so much hate yeah they
always compare him like
no one like people always like kobe is
good but there said he was better than
jordan yeah so now when you say lebron
actually statistically and is better
than jordan it triggers people yeah i
think that's why he gets the hate yeah
100 percent um i think it's also the
changing of the teams to win i think
he's only started like the super teams
like yeah i think he was the first one
to do that and then he went back to
cleveland but he went back to cleveland
when they stacked it and but they
stacked it oh when he went back yeah
yeah they stacked you know it's all
[__] and then you know and then he
went you know again to me like you have
to do with what's best for you like who
gives a [__] who gives a [__]
he's still the best guy on that court
hands down no matter what team i don't
care if you stack the team
when lebron walks on that
that court he's the best player on the
court
am i right or wrong for santa uh i mean
he's getting a little older he's a
little older why leonard uh
oh yeah kawhi is a monster
and then kevin durant
yeah they're freaks man because lebron's
like 610 isn't he yeah have you seen a
son
yes beast beast beast mode man brawny
and now brony and wade are playing
together in the same high school team
that's right um
which it looks just like his dad
my son looks nothing like me
really yeah and i look like no one in my
family
you think you're adopted i don't know
where i came from i agree with that i
think i was stolen that makes sense yeah
no i'm slowly morphing into my father
really yeah
yeah the older i get i'm starting to
hunch
and i mean and then my face i'm like god
damn it that's my dad right there i know
yeah i shaved i looked just like my dad
my sons are spitting him my son's my
twin
really
spot on we look identical when i was his
age we look identical he's bigger than
me
that's gonna be cool that's gonna be
cool when he gets bigger than you i
think my son's gonna be taller than me
and i think that's pretty cool i want my
shoulder
my son's 16. oh see i mean
yeah and man such a cool kid
hands down the call oh by the way i went
to the manny pacquiao fight
i can't believe i just i can't believe i
just said my second bro i was second row
look at that
play that play that
look at this this is what he knocked him
knocked him down in the second
second i thought he was going to finish
it first i thought he was going to
finish him the second round right there
how happy are you oh i was so happy you
look you look pretty fly there yeah i'm
only yeah i'm trying he said come on
come on yeah you know what you ever have
a stylist
my son's my stylist is he but i've
always come on man you know
you always fly but sometimes you know
it's a big game or you get something you
know you want to dress who knows i throw
it on pretty nice man you know that uh
that's your son there that's my son your
son gets a set of lips on him bro
the lobster that's the only that's the
only word you can say for my son's lips
jay-z lips p dude people would pay a lot
a lot of money for my son's lips dude he
has kylie jenner lips yes yes yes and
i'm this isn't a bad thing this is a
great that's a great i got some lips on
me you got to settle it i got a nice set
list but that kid right there dude those
are voluptuous thick kardashian's like
come on in there's only two words that
can describe my son's lips voluptuous
and uh scrumptious
scrumptious
just crunches
he has scrubs
juicy
every now and then i've seen this one
time with my son he smiled and grease
popped out like a like a pot roast just
play this video i'm done well done
look at him he's got his versace shades
on dude he's a good looking kid yeah my
son's fly [__] man i'm just i'm not
gonna lose her dope yeah my son can
dress he knows how to shop
is he uh do you have a ton of
girlfriends right now is he into that
yeah they love him they the ladies love
my son russia
who's that kid that's his best friend
well one of his friends from school
who's that's dania they're both russians
he's russian yeah they're both russian
yeah yeah yeah that's what i said to him
i mean both of them can kill you though
by the way summer in russia oh any rush
yeah dispose of your body yeah no one
will even know so you want to go what's
your son into questions today uh my son
uh
he's just cool as [__] is that okay with
you guys
are his are his friends aware of how big
deal his dad is yeah 100 they know
what's up yeah but i do i do cool [__]
man
one time like okay like all his friends
were at the the house one time and i was
like let's go to vegas
they're like all right let's go and i
literally got like you know jet yeah we
all went to vegas and we and literally
hours came back came right back i mean
and we did everything but we landed in
vegas we hit the stratosphere road every
ride
uh like we went to my restaurant eight
we we did all kinds of like [__] there
the one kid said
he goes we did more in one day than that
i would have done probably all year like
that's what he said and then we got
right back on the plane we flew back you
know he went back home and his dad was
like dude [__] jokes yeah yeah they were
all like you know what [__] [__] [__]
your friend's son yeah [__] that guy
[__] him yeah is he working no um but
but
they know that you're like a super
successful comedian oh yeah the whole
you know yeah the school knows
but the problem does he go to school
where there's other celebrity kids oh
yeah
but then but i it's cool
like
because it's like i have these hoodies
you know yeah
but he has like
some friends that have like big name
parents you know what i mean so it's
like he's kind of grounded like that
he's he's cool man
and the school's cool
like there's fans in the school like the
teachers and stuff know who i am and
yeah and i made this this hoodie that i
made and it says crew on the chest
because i really all when i was
when i would go to concerts i always
loved watching uh i always liked looking
at the what they were wearing backstage
and it would say crew loved it so i made
this hoodie that says crew and it's my
tour shirt oh yeah you should send me
one thank you
yeah and like everyone loves it and then
and then it has like the flags on them
yeah put the flags on the side it says
crew
everyone thinks that all right okay you
can have as many thanks dude as many as
you want wholesale thanks man
and uh
so everyone at a school has one i gave
school like to all the kids and stuff
yeah man it's just
it's just my like like i work really
really hard i'm always on the road i
miss out on a lot of my son's
you know things and that's my way of
just showing like i'm not trying to say
like did you miss out when he was young
yeah man
that tears you up right yeah like right
now i'm getting teary and it's like
that's why like when i'm i'm not trying
to brag when i say that stuff i just i
it's just
like i've worked so hard and that that's
my way of showing my son like yo dude
this is why you i did this i know i
missed those days yeah but you got to
understand this is why anything
understands that but there's a there's a
fine line and being a good parent and
you're working hard to build that life
and there's been a [__] dad i have some
friends who are [__] dads yeah and i i i
judge the [__] out of it yeah
i just because i'm busy too but there's
i if dude every night i don't care how
busy i'm i put my son to sleep i wake up
with him yeah i got home at two in the
morning from the comedy store i was
about 5 30 my son i don't care what the
[__] is that yeah man come to bed i wake
up with them yeah i'm on tour every
night exactly that's that and that's so
cool like it
that's so cool that you do that and i
always tell people that because
they always think like oh yeah but
you're not home
and and like when you know when when
you're home you get to be with your
somewhere and i'm like well are you
because i've seen la traffic yeah i've
seen what time you had to leave to get
to your nine o'clock job you gotta leave
at seven seven thirty for sure so you're
already gone at 7 30 and you get off at
six so you probably get home about 7
30am so how much time are you really
with your kid i'm not in no way am i
disrespecting you but i also want you to
know yeah it's simple it balances like
yeah i'm gone
thursday friday saturday but when i'm
home sunday monday tuesday monday
thursday i'm there but yeah we're
changing
it's to the point where my son's like
hey can you get the [__] out of here
don't you have to go to like texas dad
correct
so like you know there's that but
there's that kind of uh
and i don't say burden there's almost
this like resentment like sometimes when
i'm on the road and like i'll facetime
my girl or like when he was like one
she's like oh he took his first step oh
well i was in nashville yeah it killed
you right oh dude i remember i tell my i
try to i tell my girl this i try to
remind her like especially with the
potty training like my girl was like i
uh i quit i like i need a breakout go
take a break i got him and i told her i
went remember he's only gonna be this
age for
this long that long i'm telling you as
much as you hate this oh my god you're
gonna wish he was this small and we were
going through this
i'm telling you we're gonna we're gonna
wish we were yeah these days i say that
because it's all the [__] times he's
so [__] cute yes i'm like i'm telling
you man when he's 16 you're gonna wish
we're potty training right yup and i i
don't i can't do it in my career but i
can do it in life where i go this is
this is a moment you need to acknowledge
this i can't do in my career but there's
certain times where i can go make sure
you remember this make sure you realize
what's going on yeah i can do it my son
to the fullest which i'm so thankful of
and i can do it uh uh in comedy like at
the comedy store i'll have nights where
um like we i get off stage and it went
well for me and then we're in the
parking lot hanging out it's like joey
diaz rogan burr sebastian theo count and
it's just like
it's like the best time ever and i can
get my car and i click i go god damn
that was cool man yeah mark that one
down yeah remember to mark that one down
yeah
and hopefully someone like troy conrad
might get a picture and i'd text him
this yesterday i went please please
print that out for me so i can frame it
yeah because that's just picture you in
the parking lot i went you don't
understand man
it was one of the best nights of my life
yeah i paid no money
i did things went well for me and those
are my guys yeah like i can't
acknowledge like that was a special
moment yeah i don't understand people
that don't like uh appreciate those
moments like i you ever have that friend
that's just like
i just want to get out of here oh this
sucks
it's like yo enjoy those moments man
because they're they're not guaranteed
tomorrow so like you have to do though
man in my career i'm so bad at it
because
[Music]
that what you said about your son i said
that like i did uh my one special part
it was uh what special it was lights out
it was my comedy central special and i
said i'm gonna hold my son until he's
21. yeah like i'ma carry him because and
what i was saying is hold your kid oh
dude when your kid cause i always saw
where that joke came from is i remember
seeing uh i was at like a toys r us or
some [__] and i saw a kid go
pick me up daddy big man he's like you
gotta walk on your own you gotta start
learning how to walk and i remember
seeing that and i looked at my son and i
literally picked him up
and i was like i'm gonna hold you all
the time because there's gonna come a
time where you said uh where you said
you don't wanna get picked up anymore or
there's gonna come a time where i go i
can't pick you up anymore and i don't
want that to happen today yeah so i'm
gonna pick you up i used to walk around
magic mountain my son i swear to god you
guys like 10 11 years old holding my son
because he said his legs are tired i
swear to god no problem with that i
swear to god he was like damn my legs
are killing me i'm like yo come here bro
and i'm literally got this kid his
ankles are touching my ankles he's just
and i'm and i'm happy to see him i don't
give a god magic mountain and i know
because i'm saying i know i won't be
able to do this oh dude i held him i'm
in my son's grill as soon as he wakes up
as i'm home i am in his good health dude
enjoy those moments
i don't i heard this one parent go
hey stop baby talking and i'm just like
yo what are you talking about yeah let
him decide when he wants to start like
let him just be him but the other thing
and i never realized like i remember my
dad my mom said that to me really my mom
said that to me and i i remember like
like
i think parents forget that kids really
do
take that [__] in
like it's more than just words and like
for me to remember that my mom tattooed
yeah man i have certain moments where my
parents didn't didn't think i was aware
i knew what was going on it's tattooed
tattooed yeah and you you can't delete
it it's in there and it's triggers for
you yeah man and i remember my mom go
stop talking like a baby
you're older now let's stop talking and
i remember her saying that it just hurt
my feelings like i know wait a minute i
i am the baby you're a baby yeah i know
what do you what do you mean by that i
didn't say that to her but you're
thinking yeah because i remember saying
that and i was just like whoa that was
that's a little harsh like why would you
say that to me i'm not i'm not trying to
talk like a baby i'm i am a baby and i i
don't yet not i again i don't think they
remember like i remember my i was super
i must have been it's one of the only
memories i have when i was a kid because
i've been knocked down so many times but
i remember i was like maybe two or three
yeah my dad would always buy that i
think it's called cosmopolitan ice cream
where is that what's called where's
neopolitans
oh yeah yeah neapolitan but it was it
was chocolate vanilla and strawberry
yeah and i remember he it was like like
the ghetto [__] and it was in that
square box
and i remember i was so young man i was
sitting on my on my couch and you only
ate chocolate and no i ate just a
strawberry oh strawberry i ate all of it
yeah and my dad must've remember eating
just strawberry and then chocolate and
then you just have this stick of vanilla
coming up the middle no i just ate i ate
just the vanilla strawberry left the
chocolate oh you don't like chocolate
the chocolate what the [__] kind of kid
are you yeah we're white so oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah so but i remember my
dad was mowing the line outside he came
in he must have been thinking about
strawberry he's like i just want my
strawberry ice cream and he came in he's
like what the [__] he was like probably
all he wanted he's like what the [__]
the ice cream and then i'm like on the
couch and he goes oh and he's he goes
he said something like uh
something about being fat and mary said
something like are you fat ass but just
like but not like you fat ass just like
ah [__]
like something like this bad ass hate it
yeah yeah just be like ah you'd be fat
ass like joking around but i was young
man tattooed really it's like one of the
triggers i have now wow i always like
are you in the best shape i'm like i'm
fat i'm fat i'm fat yeah dad yeah dad he
had no idea but i thought but but i'm
i'm aware of it now where my girl say
someone nope no no you can't do that you
can't do that yeah here's why i went
trust me he can download the data we
have no idea how it's going to come out
down the road wow no idea so you'd be
super that's cool i'm glad you said that
yeah cause there there are some words
but i i say stuff to my son but i'm
joking with my son and maybe i should
hold baby he's 16 though yeah that's
true he's good now but i've been saying
to him since he was 10.
depends what you say to him
like [__]
cleaning room [__]
well that's all right
well there was this guy but i want okay
hold on let me let me let me clean this
up real quick i i would talk like that
to my son but i also let him talk like
that to me
so you guys so that's how i just there's
like a best friend relationship there
yeah i would be like clean your room
[__] he's like whatever [__] like
he would do that
and i was cool with it as long as long
like right back at you yeah yeah no as
long as he was
in the joking which you can tell now if
he was like if i go hey you got to eat
each carrot whatever i never said that
to him i did yeah then it'd be like a
[__] a hilarious but b
that's so true yes but i i was always
open with my son when it came to like
talking like that my son said uh uh he
he said uh
[__] to a pe teacher i mean i have a
trio you remember the trio phones it was
like right before the iphones came out
bring that up there's a big big ass
phone that you could download and watch
videos on it's called the trio it was a
big phone i remember it had a antenna
thickening yeah thick antenna it was
like a black
and that was gangster you had that the
palm tree yeah dude when you had that
people thought you were something you
were basically yeah you were you were
john clooney yeah yeah you were you were
rich yes i was at nordstrom rack you
were rich so i had to have that so uh
and i have it stored it's on that phone
i i wonder if i can get it or something
i don't know the passcode or anything
but i remember his teacher calling me
and this is like the third grade and she
was british or some [__] she's like uh
mr koi well my real name's herbert mr
herbert your son said [__] to the pe
teacher today and we need to really
discuss the way your son talks to the
teachers that's going on okay i called
her i went and talked to my son i was
like you can't do that anymore blah blah
and i went promise her do it happen
again right
second
the next day
mister
his son said it again
i told him that he had to come in and he
said why the [__] [__]
did you even talk to your son i'm like
god damn and joe i'm laughing
hysterically because one
when a british person says [__] it's
even always hysterical
and the fact that she's repeating what
my son said the fact that he's better
why the [__] what the [__] for
why the [__] i'm playing basketball what
the [__] you guys going for
it's so hilarious dude i wish and just
the way she said it
it's it's i wish and it's tough not to
laugh at those moments yeah man so
especially if you have a if you have a
comic mind it's so
half not like my right now with my son
with the potty training like we have to
take away he's so stubborn we have to go
to extreme measures to make him
understand you can't do this yeah
because he's so gangster about this yeah
so he loves he still loves his uh
the pacifier he only does every now and
then inside the house but he he loves
him like i love coffee yeah he's
addicted to him so my girl goes this
morning because he [__] his pants she
goes all right we're getting rid of your
your your uh your sucker oh [__] and she
goes look he has a lion once he's had it
since he was
one day old it's his favorite one she
takes it she goes look
mom's throwing in the trash because you
keep shooting your pants still in the
trash and i was like oh it's going to be
world war three in here
she dropped in trash he looks like he
goes i have others
did he really and i had to turn my back
and went i was so proud of him yeah turn
my back went and i started laughing and
she was do not laugh and then he went
upstairs i went i have others he's so
wait he really said i have [__]
he goes i have others i want a cool kid
i went i could not be more in love with
this kid yeah she goes no no don't
celebrate this i go
to that that's like you burning my
ferrari yeah can you imagine if you did
that and you walked out and i went i
have others i have others you know
gangster yeah it is yeah she goes you're
an idiot i went he's awesome i i'm gonna
buy him a toy yeah she goes you can't
buy him toys i went i find this show off
yeah i find that gang i have others i
have others and then you took a [__] in
his pants anyways [__] his pants i have
others and
and i just took a [__] what's up now i'm
gonna go play i have others in an ass
full of kaka dude you know what the
other thing is with kids cousin they say
you shouldn't shelter your kid with cuss
words they say it's actually not the
thing to do what uh to say don't cuss oh
you [__] that you gotta lem cuss and go
when we only use this word at home or
know when to use it like and i've
i didn't realize how fast like two years
can pick [__] up and i i play music all
the time we always there's always music
in the house non-stop my son's always
dancing and stuff and when the kanye
west video came out you know you're such
a [__] hoe
i love you oh my god
it's it's the little puppy and he's
singing it but they're doing this yeah
he likes the beat
i love it so every day papa papa papa
papa and he point to the one you wanted
to watch i wasn't even thinking the
words
and then we get this call from his p his
teacher hey he's saying he he's saying
oh [__] [__] no oh that's great
and she goes i don't know where he's
getting that if you talk like that i'm
like it's a it's a kanye west song
that's actually a little pump larry yeah
she's a hundred years old she's like
what like what it's a little pump lick
you know i'm playing this video that's
my bad i won't do it so we define the
you know the kids version
but
yeah i you know it's funny that you said
that because i had a i had a similar uh
i didn't know my son was absorbing but
not only absorbing but knew it and i
remember hugging him when i got out of
my car and i was listening to jay-z
and uh and it was 99 problems and when i
i remember turning off the car
and as i opened up the door my son
finished the rest of the year and that
was my first time ever hearing my son he
was like
why because i'm young and i'm black and
my hat's real low yeah do i look like a
mind reader i don't know
and when he did that one i was like
you know [__] words and i hugged him
crazy it was crazy yeah they like
download data man you have no idea where
it comes from it's pretty crazy man
you gotta like
god damn now i gotta like now i'm like
thinking about what i say with my son
now or like
certain like things like uh
like the movie boss baby there's this
guy he's barely in the movie and he
doesn't talk but he laughs he goes
so my son he was doing something i went
he was papa boss baby i went that's boss
baby seen it two years but he remembers
that weird guy going
i had to put on buzz man these kids man
they're sponges let's do some crazy i
hope my son uh does stand up do you
really yeah he's been hinting
he's been hinting it name the best
stand-up comic whose dad was a
successful stand-up comp
you know oh
yeah that's true because usually
stand-up comics don't come from
your dad buying flights and you know
david wayne jr he's funny he's really
funny mm-hmm
that's the only one i can think of right
now there's not i mean
i used to i thought jim carrey's dad was
comic but he wasn't
there's not you know like father-son
comics
i like to see it though i like to see uh
i like to say i'm not saying yeah yeah
you know like allen said the same thing
it was all my times you made a comic at
least seven so it's relaxed but the
other thing is yeah countless son is
seven but his son looks 36 already i've
seen his son yeah he looks old and
bright yeah
um
well robin thicke masters they're just
duos they're just kids when you think
about comedy i mean
it's just because you know it depends
how you like
the to be a comic like comes from a
weird place yeah you're right but you
can't say comics don't come from money
because [__] uh nick kroll
his dad like owns half the united states
or whatever what is that insanely rich
yeah
it curls fantastic yeah yeah very funny
i just saw stiller
that was great that's a good one that's
a good that's a good question
yeah they're hilarious oh his dad is so
[__] oh so funny
like straight stand up it's like yeah
yeah i never thought of that
i just don't want to see him i want to
see him do it i'm just saying you know
like
but in professional sports there's like
uh there's some weird stat now
especially in the nfl and nba it's like
uh someone's uh is related to to so when
their family members with an uncle
whatever it is played in nfl it's like
something like yeah it's 65
yeah have family that was also
professional yeah that's great they're
in the nfl
it's crazy it's like they're like a farm
yeah it's like the family's like a farm
yeah it's strange it is strange and
there's still it's the opposite kind of
santa's complete opposite i didn't even
think of that my son's funny though man
fighting too though fighting's kind of
upset too because
yeah i mean you you know you don't you
don't become a fighter because you have
a ton of options and you sleep in silk
sheets it comes from you know darkness
man yeah comedy comes from you know
there's a chip there's a darkness there
yeah there's a struggle knuckles it's
tough yeah you're right i don't even
think of that
he's funny i'd like to see it he hinted
so we'll see but even but even like
they're like crystal is that super
successful yeah we're just one of the
funniest people i know yeah but he there
must have been some sort of
darkness or void or tension that you
seek and become stealthy yeah but that's
two different things though because bill
is a producer director
and chris is a stand-up community i'm
just saying his dad was super successful
entertainment oh i see what you're
saying yeah so
you know
he didn't come from like this this
struggle where he's like i gotta figure
it out because i'm sure chris could have
other plans where he could have got a
job with his dad or something i think
his only struggle chris's only struggle
is that his brother's better looking
than him
his brothers yeah matt's matt's a much
better looking
family member i think he's the best
looking one out of the two and then any
other i think that that [__] with chris
that [__] with chris that [__] with
him and now he's starting now his
brother started his own podcast too yeah
and that's gonna probably
yeah matt dalia matt talia yeah let me
get a picture of matt delete there he is
jesus christ
where's matt at there's matt right there
look at [__] it's like it's like matt
and then jesus christ
i mean and then there's chris
boring
you're shooting a move in albuquerque a
big movie oh that's awesome yeah he's
like i love chris man i i remember when
i saw him at
uh haha
and i was you know i was i i was already
uh how long ago is this this is about
12 years ago and i i was starting to
become a like a there's chris yeah
coming on that he's on the back on the
post yeah
there's chris what are you going to say
though uh i saw him at the haha it was
about 12 years ago i think
and um
i'm starting to headline improvs
and uh and i just go there it's like
it's like a wednesday you know what i
mean
and uh and i see chris go up there
and there's like five people you you
know the haha the old haha by the way so
and i just remember there's like five
people and he's killing like he's you
know i mean
and i walked up to him and i was just
like i met him a couple times before
through jason
collins and then i i was just like hey
you want to go on the road with me like
open for me
like you're funny dude
and uh and i just that's what i i was
like i wanna i want this in front of me
yeah i mean like this is gonna step my
game up
so
yeah he's he's he's always been a killer
he's so funny man i took him on the road
for about a year and a half year and a
half yeah and then but did he go from he
went with you and then he was on the
road with brian and dove that was later
later was that later later yeah yeah
yeah he he was on the road with me
initially like that i think that was his
first time out on the road and doing uh
like improvs and [__] like that and
would you guys hang out a lot always
yeah that's all we did man it's a good
hang oh yeah yeah it was fun and you
know he was he was a baby then that was
that's when he was
young young i think he was only in for a
couple years three years
his thing with uh eminem was not
funny he's just i told him too i went
you got to realize like that i can't
remember last time a comic did something
that with that exposure like that's the
biggest thing man i need you to know how
big that is yeah that's eminem played
you because you
did something silly in your car and
pretend you're eminem now eminem
pretended he was actually oh do you
realize how big that is oh it's great
yeah of course man you're [__] that's
not even iconic anymore that's a god
that's like he's he's a rap god
but um
but what
my favorite one that he did was the one
in the garage of his house
i think that's the one for me like
the other ones before that were just
okay
the one in the garage it's amazing
i [__] i remember i remember texting
him going i can't stop laughing it's
like so funny man do more of these
please napkins
ah this is so [__] stupid
yeah he's stupid so yeah yeah yeah what
a compliment
he's stupid it's the best compliment we
can do yeah yeah
matt dalia everybody
you know what guys if you a thick boy
like me thick with three c's and you
work out all the time you ever just work
out your shoes just
fall off they just melt apart has ever
happened to you if you're working on
going these shoes suck
i need something more out of my shoe i
need something without all the bells and
whistles just the nitty gritty
no bull workout shoe that's right no
bull that's what i need no bull is on a
mission to create products built for
people who train hard day after day
listen they don't ask me to post on
social media i'm such a fan of this damn
company i post it because i'm like
people need these people need these in
their life i use them for my deadlift i
use them to run in i use them to do
everything and squat everything they're
the best looking most functional workout
shoe with no
gimmicks don't let the simple design
fool you either no bulls gear is built
to perform strictly for performance they
just happen to look dope as well
that's right whatever you need whether
you're cross training weight lifting
intervals cardio whatever you need no
bull they got you covered they got
runners trainers apparel they got it all
check them out for simple durable and
functional training gear visit
nobleproject.com
fighter
wouldn't be on the show if it wasn't the
best workout gear that i could possibly
provide to you guys i reached out to no
bull to work with the show because i
believe in the products that's why
they're on this that's why i'm telling
you about them that's nobleproject.com
fighter
p r n-o-b-u-l-l-p-r-o j e c t dot com
slash fighter training gear for people
who work hard and don't believe in
excuses visit nobleproject.com
fighter get your gear today you're
welcome stay swole so matt and bill
dalia everybody
[Laughter]
so a girl made a tweet saying that her
mom ordered some plus-sized clothes from
forever 21 and they sent an
lemon-flavored atkins bar inside which
is a diet bar it's low carb and low
sugar
and she may she put it out there that
they sent it with the clothes because it
was
plus size not regular size forever 21
came out and had to apologize for it and
they said that it wasn't actually just
for plus-sized clothes it was for all of
their shipments within a certain time
but
what there was a promotion there was a
cross-promotion between
atkins bars and forever 21 clothing
that's such a stupid collab yeah the
worst that's the worst [__] i've ever
heard and forever 21 does this pretty
often with a lot of different products
it just so happens that this particular
cycle was atkins bar sometimes they'll
do like lotions or
some sort of like
hey here's the other company
were they wrong no
i know everyone's upset were they wrong
could she not use a low-carb bar can we
like if i were some workout gear and you
put in a [__] slim fast like i get it
yeah i get it i get it i get message
received what are you really mad at what
are you mad at are you mad at yourself
yeah are you mad at the bar
you mad that forever 21 we're like we
know you're plus size hey look try this
bar out low carb maybe you dig it maybe
next year you're size smaller yeah
this section
of our store doesn't really sell much
we want to get you in this section yeah
we want you in this section
and you can get the ball section
eat this bar eat this bar just heat it
up one a day here's your first one first
one's on the house yeah
you're gonna love it we wanted to stick
a cheeseburger in here
but it wouldn't be good by the time we
got there but butcher i already had one
today
or three here's a low carb bar there's a
low carb bar lemon flavored
enjoy fat shaming works bro
fat shaming works
it rip this the only way to lose weight
remember when your dad called you a fat
ass look at me now
remember
come get your [__] strawberry ice
cream now this guy beat a corrosion a
croatian what's up dad
where was he from croatia he was from
croatia and it's because you talked [__]
to me
when you called me a fat ass for eating
vanilla strawberry ice cream took that
[__] out on merco croat cop
look at this look at this title around
my waist i'm not crow cop out i went
it's my ice cream it's my ice cream
strawberry
he went wild strawberry that's why his
coach was going vanilla vanilla
strawberry vanilla vanilla strawberry
shown vanilla vanilla strawberry
vanilla
vanilla strawberry oh god that was a
that was a killer combo right there
show them chocolate show them chocolate
my dad had no idea chocolate is awful by
the way chocolate chocolate elbow i hate
chocolate elbow wing snap
all i'm saying is fat shaming works man
that's all i'm saying gave me a ufc
career
it fuels me in comedy
[Laughter]
i wouldn't be mad
if i ordered some shoes from stockx and
they threw in a [__]
pack of beef jerky you know like yeah
maybe try this out brendan try this out
man we see you taking pictures of our
shoes on instagram your ankles are fat
as [__] try this beef jerky yum but if
you're tricky you need to lose something
just be cool right around the ankles
just be cool your ankles are your ankles
look like an elephant in our shoes
so stupid yeah but hey listen fat
shaming works man that's the point that
we're getting here
i'm not mad at forever 21.
yeah throw them in there man you're the
only one you're sliding
you're promoting health
it's a diet bar eat one of these please
yeah you should be upset if they threw
in [__] cocaine then there'd be a
problem then be mad yeah
well what would they really be mad at
imagine if they did stick how about if
they stuck a box of twinkies in there
do you not like him
chances are you probably would have ate
the whole [__] things oh here's
another elephant in the box elephant in
the box
can i just say one more thing
how much you want to bet that customer
after the picture was taken he takes
that bar here
like this
this is how fast
and it washed it down with water didn't
even chew
it's not low carb if you eat 19 of women
yeah yeah that's all carb after that
yeah most weighted snickers all i'm
saying is forever 21 gets it man yeah
maybe my marketing plan nothing wrong
with that
you can't get mad at that i'm sorry no
what else yet jen
[Music]
so a woman was removed from an american
airlines flight because she got in a
fight with her man and ended up smashing
his laptop over his head yeah i saw this
video by the way have you seen this no
oh you're gonna love this dude that
would hurt your oh wait till you hear it
shut the [__] up
is this brian calling his wife
[Music]
wait till you see her i know that's the
best part this is the best part
watch it watch this here it comes
listen
why [__] i let him be like that i'm not
ever going to see you again i swear to
god would you ever come to my house
[__] i'll call the police on you [__]
you oh really you're going out of
control
right now
you shut the [__] up
oh
well this is the greatest video of all
time yeah [__] you memo
i'm going over here
fine whatever
fine whatever fine i'll see you like
fine whatever just get my glitter purse
fine whatever i'll just see you out
there like no dumbass get arrested yeah
going to go and bombs what happened
she actually left so quickly police
weren't able to find her they're still
looking for her right now they couldn't
find the pink [__] backpack no and
they contacted the guy and he refuses to
give her up oh that's love yeah that's
love right there are you scared oh true
she's scared she looks like she put some
hands on him hands
hand did you see her she cracked that
laptop over his head well it started
precise shut up ninja and then and you
could always like my bad all right i'm
be cool yeah yeah yeah you can tell she
whips his ass i don't condone domestic
violence but when a girl is that big you
over 200 pounds
yeah that's why i don't gotta hit him to
the body here's another thing this is
why i don't wear silly hoodies because
if you get your ass kicked in one of
those hoodies now he looks ridiculous
now you look like a [__] [__] when
he got on the plane i like the tie-dye
yeah you hit over the head with laptop
now you're an [__] you look like a
clown you look like a joke yeah man i
always say that to people here's the
other what you wear remember
do you want to get your ass kicked in
that outfit if you're on world star
hip-hop are you still going to look good
here's the other thing could both of
them
use that low carb bar yes yes yes yes
yes they both of them could yes look how
ridiculous this hoodie is yeah that is a
horrible hoodie to get your ass kicked
in it has mushrooms on it it has no i
think they're astronauts different
colored astronauts
oh and a mushroom yes
it's a lot going on and and he's about
what 32
uh yes about 32. and i'm not talking
about his weight size no no no he is
that boy six point nine two million
views
this is so amazing a because it's a a
super white girl talking like yeah and
she got mad because you looked at
another girl mm-hmm dude i was in hawaii
with my girl
elevator ding with my son ding and come
the hottest meal for europe's in your
life with these tits
in my face man can i go oh i i let you
go outside oh wow she's gorgeous though
oh wow and i just kind of like oh that's
crazy like it it's like a [__] two
ferraris you know you're just like oh
those are big titties and then she
leaves my girl goes unbelievable
what she goes unbelievable she's gonna
stare at the girl's titties and went
who didn't wait your girl said that yeah
i went who didn't stare at her titties
yeah i wasn't gawking at him her [__]
tits were everybody's face in the
elevator yeah even the 97 year old old
lady was like look at those tits yeah
it's not me being a pervert yeah
am i at hooters
yeah am i at hooters
did i order chicken wings in the
elevator yeah where the [__] are my
chicken wings yeah get your tits out of
my face yeah my girl goes i can't
believe you look at those titties i go
no no i can't believe
that you could we can't you cannot not
see those titties what do you think my
eyes were supposed to do god man it's
not my fault
like
did your girl think a lot did your girl
think that when the elevator opened and
the tits came in that your eyes were
just supposed to go
well here's that thing just shut down
but this was the argument i go all right
let's say a giant black guy gets on the
celebrator dick down to his ankles his
dick is out
and you go oh jesus i go i can't believe
you looked at his fat dick what are you
doing what do you do you're a [__] gazer
everybody looks [__] gay everybody
looked at his big dick yeah
that's no different when someone can
dick look at his own dick he can talk to
like a might like this he was like this
dick looked at his own dick and went
look at this
he mike checks his dick one two one two
dude he i i was like it's no different
than if a guy comes in with the biggest
stick in the world everyone was oh
that's a huge dick and it's out of his
pants when a girl comes on the other is
big titties in my face
everybody man or woman goes there's some
fat ass dude was she facing you or
facing the door that closed
when she came and she was facing you she
came in and that's when she caught you
looking he's kind of crowded and my girl
was here pretend i'm walking in you're
there show me how you're the hot milf
yeah and here i this is my tip
show me how you look what
oh wow
yeah well what are you doing why are you
masturbating i'm sorry i didn't know
what's happening oh my sorry god sorry
i'm sorry
it's natural man that's what you in an
elevator
jesus that's against the lord you're
still looking for me in hawaii yeah they
got away i get away dude this video's
unbelievable it's golden
golden is there anything more awkward
when couples are fighting in public
you're just oh wow
there's nothing to do like hey everyone
calm down yeah there's no there's a
force field of hate between those two
there's nothing you like you can't like
hold on timeout let's just get up you
just gotta let them figure it out that's
why cops hate going to houses that's why
they hate going to domestic violence
calls they hate it uh because how do you
handle that situation my girl's dad's a
cop and he goes you know the most
violent uh cases for us when we have
house calls do you know what
gay domestic violence what's two dudes
oh [__] because they fight like two
dudes who are in love and it's and it's
violent violent
dick to butt
all right
is it bad i can only imagine though that
how bad that is well think about what
because when regular two dudes are
fighting whether you're gay or not it's
on now now they're in now there's a
relationship there's drama there that's
dude that's that's that's bad
i i would hate to be a cop getting a
call
to a domestic but imagine getting a call
today have you ever done a ride how do
you how do you do that have you ever
done a ride-along no might not we should
film you me doing a ride-along really so
much let's do it i did it in college it
was almost depressing thing in my life
really
they brought me they had all like uh the
when i played at cu they had all the
football players like go with the cops
estab's relationship so the guy goes i'm
you're on the midnight shift i'm like
right these two cops pick me up i'm in
the back by myself
uh 10-4 off uh boulder and 14th we have
a woman threatening suicide come in
so like uh we better get there man they
go she's not threatening come in the
house with us like
i don't feel safe i don't have a gun or
like yeah yeah yeah yeah like no just
come in we go in it's like he's
threatening to kill herself
like she used she was going to take
pills and like her cats are there
i'm like what if i'm i'm 21. yeah i
don't want to see this no
it was so dark that's all we did we were
there for four hours they're like well
thanks for coming man we'll drop you off
and i'm like all right thanks dude yeah
thanks for all right can you give me
post if she did it or not yeah
you know i never heard
thanks again now i want to kill myself
she had seven cats in there oh all right
it was so sad yeah but she would do like
a real right along let's do it i'm down
no i don't want to see any of that [__]
oh no i want to be like freak
nah i can't i can't [__] do it
i i i can't that's why i shoot out the
window
ah [__] man you don't want any of that i
had a gun pulled out on me that was one
of the weirdest weirdest [__] things
i've ever experienced we're at [__]
big ass glock like concrete what
happened i froze like this
what happened look at it right here oh
there's nothing that's all i did
and then my friend was like this
you guys have no idea what to do my
friend was literally looking at the gun
like that
and he goes are we cool oh
absolutely
definitely cool everybody's cool
everybody's cool man well he was just
trying to rob you guys
uh it was a car situation that we were
in and it was just mouthing off and then
he pulled out the gun i was just like
god damn it it's crazy how powerful guns
are it yo it was like my here's what i
was mostly scared about
how about if we hit a bump oh or a car
you're paul kitchen you're marvin in
pulpit yeah literally like that yeah
that's what i was thinking i was
literally thinking that because i was
like yo dude move that gun i know like
just move it up like face it towards
that's what i was saying to myself but
he had it like he had like that
and i'm just like god they're so scared
i have guns in my house now and for him
to show us under the seat which is like
so scary i had a gun pulled on when i
was high school i mean my three friends
were all in red like idiots we didn't
know and we were walking like a seedy
area in aurora where i grew up and this
guy this black dude wrote like ah she's
probably older than us spraying 20
something at that time because him
because why are you boys all flamed up
and i thought he meant like why is our
like why are we breathing hard because
why are you wearing red yeah yeah and i
was like i'm sorry why am i flamed up
and you know i was like trying to just
talk with him and then he go he has a
gun like this i'm like oh [__] that's a
gun he goes take your [__] jackets
off and i was like oh yeah no problem
like whatever yeah whatever you spit on
him and i was like what the all right
bro i just got this from old navy i
appreciate it not spitting out you're an
old navy blood
you're an old navy blood
i literally just got this from old navy
i appreciate the break on that spin and
i remember i was even under those
conditions i was still pretty cool and
my one buddy was suit just super nerdy
takes us off and they gotta go spit on
it without any hesitation
i was like dude chill yeah you don't
need that much spit i remember thinking
how powerful that gun was i remember
thinking like oh he has to suck his dick
we're stuck in his dick yeah like
there's we just went out yeah there's
nothing to do
that was that was the craziest [__] i've
ever seen there's like it's not like the
movies were like
yeah got no that's not real because the
guy's like this i thought i went hey
guys
my friend's like dude what the [__] was
brendan doing he shot him right in the
face he shot him right in the face
hey yeah
oh i love it i love it when they show
you on youtube just how quickly you can
grab the gun i'm like never dude if i
can practice that a million times i'm
getting shot oh dude if i'm alright yeah
why are you flamed up here you'd be like
what are you do
what do you do why would you do that why
did you do that like i saw jackie chan
do it that's really hurts yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
that's exactly exactly what would happen
this is what his this is him holding on
and this is me doing that move that i
saw on youtube and this is him not
letting go all right
yeah this seemed good all right let's
see him go what are you doing
dude no i'm gonna shoot in the face yeah
bro that was i'm telling you man i can't
even tell you
what that was like i can't i can't even
explain it it was crazy like the biggest
like you have no control there is none
i can get why people feel empowered when
they have guns oh it's power and he had
a bro that because then they're like
dinette like the dynamics of your
physicality like your athletic gifts or
out the window done this dumbass who ran
up to three white kids in old navy red
coats why he flamed up has the gun yeah
all right well now all right you won
there's three of us you win dude yeah
you took my old navy coat yeah what's up
now [__] you know yeah that it was
you know what's even crazier for you to
pull out the gun
that's crazy because you're assuming
that no one else has a gun
like i saw this he had a good assumption
three white kids i know but like it's
still a brave move because for you to
pull that out you're engaging and you're
and you're basically saying if you got
one let's go and the reason why i say
that is i saw this video of this guy
going up to a bunch of women after
school i don't know if you saw this
video and he's got this he's got it
pointed out when i've seen this and he's
just assumed that none of the women had
guns and this woman pulls out that
[__] knock oh it was a glotch like
and pops them twice to the chest and
it's like that's the dangers of pulling
out a gun there's there's a there's a
double responsibility there's one you
better you better make sure whoever
you're pulling that gun out on doesn't
have a gun yep and then two
[__] are you pulling out a gun
i have a reason for that especially this
day and age like
like dude everybody has gifts everybody
has everyone wants to carry yeah well i
feel like i i told the story where
i had this meeting at cbs i get out and
this dude
starts stops my car he's mad goes out to
get to fight me and he's like this big
yeah i was like dude what about a gun
what are you thinking yeah you do you're
45 what if i had a gun yeah he's like i
don't know man
wait he came out on you yeah want to
fight fist fight in the street when was
this uh like two months ago what the
[__]
that is the craziest [__] i must have my
raptor this monster truck i'm leaving
the cbs lot yeah he veers off into
traffic and like ah i hope my horn
puts on his brake gets out and he looks
every he looks like [__] dude yeah 47
life isn't going good comes out and goes
hits my car goes like this i'm like oh
oh wait i think you told me and i get
out i'm like what are you doing dude
yeah i was like what if i had a gun yeah
the [__] are you doing
did you i mean
i think i've said this to someone before
when you get out of your car to engage
in a fight with another guy in the car
that's literally knocking on the door
and whoever opens it you fight i assume
it's so you don't know what's behind me
i assume i'm honking at mike tyson yes
don't assume you're honking at some
[__] i'm assuming i'm not getting at
mike tyson he's ak-47 so if you want to
engage in that keep doing it yeah but
assume that there's a monster behind
that
always don't assume it's some punk [__]
never i always when i drive if someone
cuts me off i'm so old now i just go
like this i'm like he's in a hurry me
too i do this oh my god you probably
have something going on person is in a
hurry and i am in his way i assume there
might get there my friend i assume it's
a pair i'm like i get it gotta get home
have a good day have a good day and they
go [__] you like
i feel you brother i feel like i i will
[__] me
will do i will [__] me i will
good suggestion i will get [__]
going to either [__] me or have someone
[__] me for you
get home have a good day
what else you got jim speed up this is
the greatest video i've seen all day
that's definitely so an australian man
crashes his van with a hundred and forty
million dollars worth of meth into a cop
car
you know
wait how is that even what around 10 30
yesterday morning here at eastwood
police station the officers inside the
station heard a loud crash a bang out
the front of the police station they
came outside and they could see two
police vehicles had been damaged a
vehicle had crashed into them
they checked the cctv they spoke to
witnesses and they identified a white
toyota high ace van had collided with
the police vehicles at the front of the
police station and taken off up ethel
street eastwood
at around about 11
30 a.m one of the inspectors one of our
senior police officers i don't think
that guy looked like that are you there
yeah
either that for me yeah was searched and
uh remarkably inside that vehicle was 13
boxes in each box contained 21 one
this is one of those things where you're
driving with a million dollars worth of
uh meth in your car hold on that's 140
million oh my god 140 million dollars of
meth in your car and you're driving by
cops going don't hit the car don't hit
it don't [__] hit the car
[__] what the [__]
that's how that happened that that's
when you that's when you don't text and
drive when you have 140 million dollars
worth of brother shipment from thailand
which was estimated worth
837 million dollars it was going where
thailand was with an estimated worth of
that's the that's a different one yeah
800 million dollars of math jesus and
was some heroin in there too what there
was heroin in there too jesus christ did
you see what he hit though hyundais
if that was a you know what i mean just
throw a couple bags of hair in here get
some also show a little pride and please
jesus
you're not catching that toyota no
toyota's gone bro what else you got jen
uh this is very sad news
um
well that's sad too
one second here we are
i brought this up to you on below the
belt on brendan's showtime show and it
was at that time at the time he brought
it up this boxer was just
his coach had stopped him in the 11th
round because he felt like something was
wrong with him right so he's cut his
coaches begging like just you can't
continue
and yo was it yesterday right
yeah yesterday he was in a coma and he
just passed away from uh
and here's his coach actually pleading
with him listen his coach between rounds
here
[Music]
okay
i'm going to stop the fight
max i'm going to stop it
max you're going to hit too much
you're going to hit too much max
oh please max please let me do this okay
okay look at me please
please you're getting hit too much max a
fighter's heart man
you understand me if i don't the
referee's gonna do it
please
please man
on max please
come on you got to be honest with me man
all right
[Music]
that's
that's it
great job
yeah heartbreaking man i mean
this is the thing i know it sucks it
should never happen but sucks but i
don't think people realize like
combat sports man this is this is why
a lot of fighters are held in such high
regard because
even if he were to win that fight your
health is always on the line yeah always
but people forget
people forget what they're doing like
these football players pretty like guy
can you do you believe he has ct and i'm
like
did you not see him over
all the past couple years playing
football run into grown men yeah at full
speed what do you think's gonna happen
yeah or in fighting when people are like
ah this is [__] this thing's just
changing boxing like hold up what did
you think was gonna happen
this is the
this is the i mean this is why you know
people watch boxing yeah because the the
stakes are so animal
yeah and it's it's so fun
what's crazy about
like with what you did
once again i'm not an athlete but like
when you guys
fight i think there's like a better
chance
i don't know how to say this i just feel
like these these boxers are head hunters
and they're constantly getting hit in
the head that's fair and yeah you're
like and i feel like it's more dangerous
like yours is dangerous don't get me
wrong
you snap with me blah blah blah but
these guys literally are just looking at
each other's heads and just bashing the
[__] out of them but here's the
difference joe so let's say um and i
feel like it's a concussion every time
they get hit every time every [__]
time here's the thing is in mma if i get
rocked right i get wobbled and the guy
finished me off the ref stops it yeah
and bought and then it's over the the
damage that i've suffered is typically
over the ref might be a little slow but
they're going to stop the fight i can't
continue on in boxing i get rocked right
yeah i get a tank count i get back up
i can kind of weather the storm i
there's obviously trauma that has been
happened to the brain i keep going i get
hit again i get rocked
there's trauma of the brain but i make
the tank count i keep going another six
rounds yeah but my brain's swelling my
brain has serious brain trauma and i'm
eating generally but i'm i'm still you
know i'm still hanging in there i get
rocky again
make the tank count so the use you
suffer way more brain trauma in boxing
man way more yeah way more yeah because
they they
hit it's over you ever see like when
they when they have those deer legs
uh like i saw
yeah
and
and then they come back and fight three
more rounds and i'm just like wait a
minute that dude was
because when they have the deer like
they're knocked out well anytime
that's knocked out right sometimes if
they get behind the air it's their
equilibrium and they're trying to find
their balance yeah but most of the time
if it's here and you see them off well
that that's a concussion that br trauma
has happened to the brain oh man but
then they make the tank and they go they
march back out so it's like this repeat
because in in football it's not the
quarterbacks not the receivers you know
suffers the most
problems the nose guard in the center
it's the alignment yeah because it's the
small hits like this yeah every play
they're guaranteed to get hit every play
the other positions all right so those
linemen are doing this
300 times a game 300 times a game just
snapping
it's the jab yeah
and people go oh it's the big shots
that's what
it's the constant the constant shots
constant shots
that that killed me right there
hey but that's a and again that's a
fighter's heart man yeah that's why
that's why you have to be but again you
have to be all in yeah man because
there's guys
there's guys that that wasn't so there's
a famous famous fighter josh barnett who
oh yeah josh babyface babyface yeah face
says one of the best fighters of all
time yeah brilliant dude child josh
burnett won the best his cornerman who i
had the same quarterman at one point i'm
sorry cut man stitch he said tell stitch
let me die in there do not throw in the
towel
so i knew he would tell stitch this you
know i told stitch my fight
if i'm in trouble you throwing that
[__] do not let me die yeah i have
way more living to do yeah that's
difference from me and josh barney yeah
man they call him the war master
there's they don't know what they call
that who cares
smart alive they call you by your first
name they call me smart they call you
they call you they call you because they
can because you're alive yeah but
somebody call you because they know
you're gonna answer but so was josh and
he was the world champion yeah that was
the difference between me and josh yeah
i went hey should we get this roughly
you thought [__] towel let me live to
fight another day yeah joshua it's by
any means necessary the war master yeah
whatever the opposite of the war master
that's me the peace master let me die in
the ring god don't you thought tell him
let me die i went you stitched i know
you guys have the hole let me die that's
[__] crazy do you ever as soon as if
we get i get if you see
this it's on that towel if you see my
hair go forward and then back real fast
if you throw that talent if you see me
yeah you throw in that towel right tell
you what stitch give me the towel i'll
throw it and i'll say you through it
how's that let's do that let's do that
stitch just put it fake it up put hide
the towel on my glove yeah i'll throw a
job and throw the talon we're done
i'm out bro we all get paid stitch when
i do this
stitch as here's here's the code word if
you see a bead of sweat roll yeah yeah
yeah yeah throwing that i'm done no just
throwing the towel i don't say anything
okay here
here's one stitch
all right
here's a code word all right i'm gonna
throw a code word and that's when i want
you to throw in the towel and this is
the code word ask me what the code word
is what's the code stop the fight
stitch here's our thing i don't i'm kind
of embarrassed i don't even know yeah as
soon if you hear bruce buffer say let's
get it on
throw the towel throw in the towel
[Applause]
if anyone says let's before the fight
throw in the [__] towel on the towel
yeah when he and if you hear someone say
my name what's your who's buffer whoever
throwing the top yeah if you don't hear
the bell ring
during the fight
throw in the towel throw this up i want
you ready to go i want you hey in fact
stitch can you stand by the bell
and hold the hammer i want to make sure
as soon as it goes man it's just
but you know uh manny pacquiao when he
fought de la hoya and everyone was like
that everyone was mad at freddie roach
because they were like they were like oh
what are you doing like manny is too
small to fight don't [__] man he was
getting destroyed destroyed because you
know de la hoya like 180 and manny can't
even get past 140 pounds if he tried
and uh and of course de la hoya they had
met at a catch weight or whatever but
manny likes manny [__] hit him so
many times
i don't even think de la hoya threw a
punch i think there was no punch count
he could have hit him yeah he couldn't
hit there was no punch count it was all
manny i mean the face was swollen and
when you got to that that round
where the coach was like
yo della
got to get out man yeah just just don't
go back in there
you can see those he's too fast yeah but
you also see him he's too fast but you
also saw de la hoya like not want to say
okay no fighter wants to do that mm-hmm
and then and then when the bell rang you
just see de la hoya get up
and walk and move towards
manny it broke my heart to
see someone like de la hoya like [__] i
can't do it this is what's crazy for
that's why the the corners are so
important in fighting because for a
fighter a fighter going you know what
i've had enough fighters say that's
basically like snitching in jail yeah
like as far as other fighters it's just
like oh what a [__] move yeah
i don't view that i mean oh what a smart
move yeah right
you're living to fight another day but
you don't become a nate diaz a conor
mcgregor uh jorge mazvidal jon jones and
anthony smith augustine or daniel
cormier going uh you're right i've had
enough you don't you just don't get to
that level yeah you just don't no those
guys are literally willing to die and
die in the ring she's insane yeah the
fighting in the career you have is such
a small sliver of your life yeah it's
such the average career is two and a
half years in the ufc library nfl cursed
three and a half years that does not
define you yeah so if you get done with
income i don't feel like doing you know
what i have had enough you have your all
your life to raise kids do where the
[__] you want yeah who cares yes man who
cares yeah but it's a different animal
though different right that's why i was
never world champion yeah i was not
wired that way that by any means
necessary yeah
yeah it's crazy
that that i that i remember watching
that like after you just after i saw
what you just showed me i remember
looking at and getting sad for de la
hoya because i knew i knew he was like
i can't beat this guy and i don't want
to quit but you're also never the same
once you realize like oh [__] i'm never
going to beat that guy yeah never the
thing yeah
that's crazy because the great ones they
they always feel like they're cut from a
different cloth yeah no one can touch
them and it's so heartbreaking it's a
humbling moment when you see someone get
touched yeah when you when they go oh
[__] i'm not god's gift to fighting it's
hard yeah man
crazy
i could never i i don't know what that
life is i don't know what you know what
i mean thank god you don't yeah yeah i
remember watching when i'm watching your
fights and i was just like god damn this
guy was a beast and for you to say like
throwing the towel and [__] like that
like
it's hard for me to understand because i
saw your fight and i think other fires
are saying go go what a [__] like i
hear you dude i hear you that's why i'm
doing what i'm doing now yeah and i hear
you and i understand how you guys have
those those words the code that you live
by i i just i never partake in that that
mindset to me is like how how can i
suffer the least amount of damage get
the [__] out of here man yeah i'm not
making that much money and then uh i've
told this story before on other fight
shows but i remember why marco krokop
used to be number one right guy in the
world he's one of my heroes when i was
getting into fighting the man biggest
win of my career i remember brutal fight
back and forth best fight in my career
i'm all [__] up and i knock them out
and everything's all good and then we're
in the back and i was just like what are
we do i remember just having the
the awareness yo looking at him look at
me we're both so [__] up and i just
like dude what are we doing i literally
go what are we doing what are we doing
look at me look at you
what the [__] are we doing i was so
upset at myself well what the [__] are
we doing man
and i then uh they get in the commission
the way they do it
you told me that story before and yeah
they joined the story they signed that
you sign right so you sign your check
commission gives me his check seven
figures he won the grants of all time
you're talking legend you should have
statues of them i see history holy [__]
and i see mine it's like 12 grand or
something no way that's right what the
[__] am i doing and i and i look at him
i go there has to be more in life to
this man there has to be more and i've
won i want there has to be more and not
only did you win those in his broken
english croatian goes this is life
this is life wow
i went nah nah wait you're no way dude
before and i i remember getting mad at
him and i remember thinking for you
[__]
i get emotional i remember thinking for
you it is man yeah not for me dude not
for me wow yes that was the moment where
like crazy i was the one where like
triggered me biggest one in my career i
remember just triggering me like for you
man for you this is life you stay here
and do this [__] i'm out man i remember
thinking i'm [__] as soon i'm [__]
out and you were out i i was mad at
myself i was mad
and and i went on to fight probably six
or eight more times after that
but that was that fight which the
biggest one in my career was the trigger
for me go i'm out man yeah this isn't it
yeah
god damn that's that's deep bro god
that's good and and
everyone remembers here's the thing
that was the crazy thing when he came
into that ring you were literally to me
i thought you were dead yeah no
seriously because cro he was crazy he
was killing everybody yeah you know what
i mean so like i can only imagine that
wind should have been celebrated by you
because you knew who that was when you
walked in am i right
but here's the problem though it was
almost like a death sentence for me
because i knew
i didn't want to do it anymore i knew my
heart wasn't in it and i knew that i
would never be world champion but i had
to act and pretend like i was all the
way in like i could beat cain vasquez i
kept calling out guys knowing i was
faking the funk
i had no other options yeah
and but i'm i'm in with i'm swimming
with sharks man and i'm a dolphin but i
look like a shark but i'm a dolphin man
and i don't want to swim with the sharks
i want to go jump through the hoops play
with the chicks
tell some jokes yeah flap my [__] fin
yeah
get fed get mackerel
low carb bars yeah if you want i don't
want to eat license plates nah i'm like
a shark i want to get the [__] free
mackerel and do a backflip
crazy man life's crazy
crazy that's that's such a cool story
man
that's so dope man
that should be shot
shouldn't that be like a
right like a cool scene like that's a
[__] cool scene right there to see
that it's crazy that if you hear me talk
like that and you watch the highlight of
me knocking out crow cops yeah and then
you hear that story like what the [__]
you talking about dude yeah no i know
honey man i was throwing up in the back
because i was so sick from from just the
trauma to my body
wow
i mean i remember going out with my
family went to this pizza place i forget
the name of it but they're all there and
they're happy and i'm miserable in a
jumpsuit made by five star that was
custom made for me made in i'm kind of
designed myself that was i was happy
about that
and i remember they had chicken wings my
mouth was so swollen i couldn't eat the
chicken wings and i remember i was
miserable wow
and then i and then some fan goes
so who's next
i wanted to go [__] you that's who's
next yeah let me enjoy this yeah which
i'm not yeah who's next
that's crazy dude big you knew you yeah
big nog in brazil is next brennan
which it was another you know like yeah
it doesn't stop me yeah it doesn't stop
it's exhausting oh
no one will know that too that's the
crazy thing like you can learn
martial arts and get as many belts as
you want and punch these bags as many
times but no one knows no one knows
about the the other killer in in that
ring there's only one way to learn and
that's what they are killers
right like that's their mindset i'm
going to kill you isn't it yeah well
it's the same like when like i remember
mark munoz asked me to talk to
the team i was training with him he
wanted to talk to team because guys were
missing practices
and i went you don't want me to do that
mark here's why i go
because if you take someone to tell you
that you have to come to practice
you're not going to make it no so i'm
wasting my time
mm-hmm so if guys aren't going to
practice just tell them not to come
anymore mark because i can't do that
you should do them a solid same with
comedy people go dude where do i start i
go just get up man yeah and then
i remember some guy goes oh i'm getting
up i go cool man and i see him uh
montague how many times you get up
because once or twice a month ago oh
you're out of the race yeah what do you
mean you have the race bro yeah you're
done i know guys who are ten times as
talented as you they're getting up seven
eight nights of [__] spots a week bro
yeah
a week man i get up six eight times
while i'm not on the road you're not
even you we're not even the same we're
not swimming in the same lane yeah we're
not having the same conversation no it's
too cute you're speaking a different
language yeah
that's crazy
still tripping about that what you told
me what you told me because i don't
think people really understand
that like as a person as a fan i enjoy
it like you saw how i was at that at
that that fight you know what i mean i'm
not a [__] i've seen you happier i've
never seen you happier at that pace i
was so happy that such a fanboy bro he
i love thank you when he threw that i
think he threw a little a right uh
like and his and his mouthpiece flew out
of his mouth and i'm second row and i'm
cheering this [__] murder take place
because that's what i mean you're
beating the [__] out of this guy and
then the guy he's fighting
has to win keith thurman's amazing and
he's amazing but like you're losing if
you lose a 40 year old man
that's on his way out it's not a good
look for a guy that's trying to make his
i didn't think keith sure took that
fight yeah i know keith keith buddy i
thought it was a terrible idea for him
to take that yeah it's just like it's a
it's a lose-lose if you lose you really
really lose you know what i mean if
manny loses he doesn't really lose
you're you're still the marquee name
you're still sitting on a hundred
million his legacy yeah you're [__]
good you know i mean you're still gonna
get another fight because people want to
see manny fight but keith
you know it's it's hard how he lost you
know what i mean
and i
and and and then hearing you say that
it's just like god damn because i
remember he was taking some did you see
his face at the end of the fight you see
keith's face i mean he had an ear bruise
bro i remember seeing that he had a
black ear i'm like yo that dude that's
gotta hurt here's my thing if anyone
goes uh i'm thinking about getting into
fighting
i won't look at that
you got to show the the it's it's the
one right there the one uh i think the
red porter
uh it'd be the far right one him yeah
that's him there his face pretty beat up
yeah so whenever someone goes oh i'm
thinking about being a fighter like that
that one right there with the lady look
at that look at that that's the one i
was looking at and even that's not too
bad that's what's bro that's right after
the fight i know so imagine the next day
oh
yeah look at his ear look at this i mean
look at that look at his eyes there's
two black eyes john jones gusman ufc 165
when everyone goes i'm thinking about
being a fire girl i want you to watch
jon jones with gus fin one ufc 165 in uh
toronto i found the same card
one of the greatest fights i've ever
seen
two of the best to ever do it they go
so hard they go so hard
oh man
yeah i remember that fight john john had
to be carried out and i remember when he
won that fight john won that fight
that's right i remember the
controversials back and forth two of the
greatest light heavyweights of all time
there they basically married each other
and i remember john we shared a locker
room and they're carrying john through
on a stretcher and he's he's he's in so
much physical pain he's like trying not
to throw up and his entire body's
shaking
no way nice grab my go
i'm so proud of you champ and i remember
he like
he was so and he was in so much pain and
he was he just left his like thumb like
this are you [__] kidding me yep
that's that's the [__] people don't see
that's right to me john's the greatest
oh hands down oh he's great and he's the
most he barely trained for that fight i
don't think he trains right i think he
just walks in he does
but not to the level of his company like
he doesn't have to what was the one guy
that he fought uh the brazilian jiu
jitsu guy old school but that he was
still
vidor belfort
that [__] fight is when i was like in
love with john jones oh you know what he
had him in that goddamn armbar broke his
arm oh it was broken oh yeah john's arm
was really he he uh extended the
ligament to everything and he still won
that fight and submitted instead of
commenting them
like
bro john has his deals outside the cage
i don't [__] with that's whatever inside
the cage
i've never seen anything like it
like i said he's a natural right
like he's just like when he fight when i
watch it this this when i watch him i
feel like there's no uh
there's no game plan it's just it's
fluid it's like water he just adapts to
what the situation is
and then just it's that natural
let me relate to you as a comic joke so
when so he's training more now but when
he fought like ryan bader or gus finn
where he barely trained and and he was a
world champion it's the biggest night of
your life and he barely put in the
effort imagine shooting the biggest
special your life the biggest mass
square garden what it the big thing as
big as you can get and not doing the
road work and not preparing yeah and
then showing up and knocking out the
park yeah no flubs nothing
past the test yeah just perfect
that that's what that was
damn dude
that's what's crazy
that's crazy
those are the guys that leave it in the
ring right
yeah oh yeah
those are the guys right
john jones is crazy
i love watching that guy fight he's so
talented that's stupid it's nuts huh
[__] but yeah yeah i almost i wish
people could understand how talented he
was like i know there is like i know you
you watch him on tv but it's like uh
like even that like he just
you're so much better man really but and
it's his his mental like yeah i don't
think he's the best athlete around a 40
i'd probably be him in a 40. yeah
his mental state think about that man
not not
crossing all your t's dotting all your
eyes staying up late doing whatever with
chicks yeah and it's been like i can
beat this guy and just end well no he is
dude but he's ranked number one in the
world and he's training right now he's
for you while you're at the strip club
and he's studying tape
dude he has all your tape he knows
exactly where i'm doing he goes yeah no
no i know he give me another drink
and then two minutes he's in bed right
now wrestling is i know he'll need the
rest i know i know no dude you
understand you're gonna go five rounds
25 minutes it's gonna be the toughest
fight in your life
i'm gonna go jet ski you still wanna you
still wanna go out tomorrow to the club
and pop bottles yeah
well that's insane yeah i know don't
worry i've have i got this
and he did
and he did get it right oh yeah twice
beat him worse the second time knocked
him out what
and not and not even train for it that's
not and he he trained but not to the
extent that a guy at that level would
to beat that guy
that guy yeah
that's nuts man
just the mental space there mm-hmm
is that it you want another one you're
good
we have do we do a six hour long i mean
me and joe i feel like this one yeah i
can talk to you all day yeah this is fun
man it's up to you guys if you want to
know the current event yeah that was
cool apparently the show has turned me
to your old fight stories just no but my
ct kicked down like and i remember this
one
that's good that was amazing though to
hear that from you i don't think a lot
of people know that about you
yeah i don't know you know
to to know that you
you at your highest level
still had like
fear like you know what i mean like like
because when we see these fighters we're
like oh fearless you know as a fight fan
oh fearless
those guys go in and that's what they do
but they they go in
scared too but same with comedy like and
especially you've been doing it so long
but i'm sure like before you shoot your
special
you don't go on going oh this can be a
breeze no never no never never
but then that's what makes you you know
what i'll say that's what makes you
great because those nerves you channel
that and turns into this this [__]
greatness yeah same with these guys
these these high-level fires those
butterflies that anxiety they can take
that and where what separates the the
sheep from the wolves is the sheep go oh
[__] butterflies go all over the
sheep go no no we're gonna go this way
dude yeah and they [__] make
greatness out of it comics do the same
thing yep
last night i'm back sebastian about to
go in the main room did he sold out
[__] mesquite around 90 000 times
whatever he's done huge shows like you
yeah he's back there pace and nervous
yeah killers man yeah i love that [__] i
love it we're all because you're like oh
well we're all we're all human
no one's above this besides jon jones no
one's above this you know what i'm
saying yeah there'll be a psychopath not
to give you
you've got to be a psychopath to have
all those people paying money to see you
and you just go oh i got it yeah i'm
going to throw it in
yeah i'm going to call it in crazy
nope i love it man is that it did you
want this i just keep chatting i'm like
the other thing is i remember my dad
were we talking about ice cream uh
this is a quick one so this is the us
coast guard they're capturing a
submarine though smuggling drugs on the
coast of mexico and look at how badass
these guys are look how badass these
guys are the others because the guys on
the submarine or the coast the coast
guards
are badass this whole thing looks like a
movie is it a legit submarine or is it
like super makeshift like it looks like
a
[Music]
why would the submarine go underwater i
know so it must be one that just hovers
just below the surface
by the way he's yelling to to john lake
was almost
dude hey sub go
see ya
yeah exactly
check this out though this is the crazy
part
he jumps on it yes
not only does it jump on here
look at this guy
he jumps on it
check this out starts banging on the top
[__]
it's gi joe holy [__] bro why didn't
they just go under
i think it's only designed to go right
there holy [__]
boom
so they got 17 000 pounds worth of uh
cocaine so it was like 232 million
dollars in the streets holy [__] usa usa
dude that was amazing but also why
wouldn't this drive the submarine go oh
you're on top cool going under yeah
also the boats i can't follow you under
why'd that go under maybe i was all the
way under i don't think that was a real
sub it looks like a
trash can lid
i don't know it's hot it's
i don't think it could go under they're
called nanko subs i think that sub was
sinking
yeah dude that was badass he jumped on
the [__] sub was like and pounding on
the door
god makes me proud to be american yeah
yeah yeah that was cool that's some that
was some uh
that was your dog man that was my dog
that was your dog full circle that's
your d
come to my house after that guess where
this guy went right after this your
house my house he takes saturdays off or
whatever sniffing your wife's vagina for
for drugs and
illegal activity
man that was amazing dude this was
amazing that was you're the best i love
you bro that was so much fun man we
gotta do some [__] together shoe shop
go with cops everything
eat jump on submarines
yeah
fights
we can go to fights disarm people with
guns we could try it i'll try i'll try
as long as the clip's empty
i'll try that i'm gonna go for it
i would say give people your dates but
it doesn't matter does it
we just added another show in uh san
diego that shit's crazy around san diego
uh the civic theater
in san diego it's sold out already
five shows it's like 15 000 people
it's insane it's great i don't even get
it look i don't even understand this
dude
because i am you [__]
oh i thought that was like one of the
filters no [__] you man what old filter
dude you look young as [__] here yeah
right what's going on there
at this hermosa beach sold out well that
wasn't even a show that that i just i
just wanted to go up and
that's that one already let's get rid of
that though yeah yeah yeah that's not a
good picture that one's great those are
crazy that's like dude
sold out 14 shows
he added more in brea yeah they won't i
went to bray and they yelled where's joe
carl
i i don't know
he's not here man
and then they all left
he was crazy man the the
i i don't
it's i'm i'm very i'm overwhelmed
it's so cool it's cool oh wait august
9th to 11th brea all sold out august
14th 18th eight shows sold out you've
sold 14 shows in brea
yeah they want me to add more those were
sold out like in january
jeez
god went over
what else can you scroll down this is
crazy i never i haven't even looked at
this
well reading still oh yes what's up
reading where are you at ready oh [__]
yourself ready yeah dude
calgary oh
two weeks oxnard six of shoulders
calgary great spot by the way calgary
yeah
i think we just added that edmonton sold
out regina sold out
those just got added today
because san diego sold out atlanta sold
out
keep going oh atlanta we added a second
show please i'm having fun looking at
this
yeah atlanta we just added that fresno
sold out
you just had a second show in atlanta
because it's so the first one sold out
keep going
by the way bowl shows at fresno sold out
oh i bet san jose you [__] slang
tickets san jose that's that's yeah
that's an arena i think
it's pretty soon you should be doing
states those are all added right now
pretty soon they're like where you're
like
just california they're just gonna give
me a mic all of california san francisco
san diego come out how many people seven
million yeah i did seven million seven
million man holy [__] like a goddamn
presidential campaign it's
where are you doing i'm doing i'm doing
canada yeah all of canada yeah i'm just
getting a mic in their internet and uh
that's right that's the level you're at
man will you come to my just come i'd
love to do a [__] do a set with the ones
whatever you want
you can come to any show man i don't
wanna hit you i'm like hey man can i
come to your show like i i don't know
and then that little bubble pops up and
disappears and this parody like
and then comes back guys i would man
it's just super packed yeah super packed
bro they're sitting in there they said
you were just here and you know maybe
what's through i would really love for
you to come in i'm gonna i'm gonna come
one in your breast shows
promise i'm in town i'm going there it's
only a seven hour drive there not a big
deal would you uber chopper there how do
you do it uh uber chopper that does
thank you yeah uber chopper in fact i
just bought that submarine that we saw i
was going to say
that i bought it fully
uh filled with cocaine probably
i bought the submarine with the cocaine
i got a good deal just to make it more
expensive a little dented up from yeah
troops whatever um well my tickets
aren't sold out i'm in nashville
next week thursday friday saturday
zany's one of my favorite clubs in the
world so good zany's nashville almost
sold out though zany's nashville
thursday friday saturday next week after
that i'm in portland the helium in
portland that's the 15th the 17th and
then just added houston uh
that is six i love that room september
hey are you in downtown or out in the
suburbs i only do downtown dog do you
you got to play i've done this
i've done that my dad lives across the
street from it oh that's a good room man
the landmark landmark is fun right
mark's fine that's where i started
landmark but now i've transitioned so
you went downtown yeah that's it i love
that that's one of the greatest rooms
ever ever that's one of the greatest
comedy rooms ever made period big shout
out to wendy yeah wendy's the best yeah
hands down where else pittsburgh i
haven't played that in years last time i
played that was with dalia
charlotte you've been there these are
october philly i've not i've never done
stampin phil oh you're gonna love philly
can't wait for philly philly
cheesesteaks dallas salt lake yep so but
this weekend i will see you guys or next
week uh nashville then after that
portland get your takes now tfk.com
check my netflix special yes coming in
hot please i can't tell you how many
people
[__]
love your netflix oh thank you
love it man thank you man love it
i didn't get my first i told you that
story right yeah my first special they
they said no and i paid for it i paid
for it i cut it up myself you just
brought a hustler dude and it's like i
feel like now there's so much content
for people's specials to really stick
out it has to be
like you're talking
tip of the spare good like it's very
rare like you have your audience but
then it's to me it's so rare especially
on netflix showtime hbo if your special
sticks out it has to be
so good or before you could kind of you
know if you had one it'd be
dude yours is so damn good thank you
brother yes it's on netflix now coming
in hot joe coy go check it out netflix i
love you man i love you bro this is the
fighter and the koi we're out